대한민국에 정말 유명한 과학 커뮤니티 2명 있다.
방송계의 침착맨
그리고 가요계의 윤하
저의 하나의 꿈이 있다면
윤하 기부 장학금에서 생활장학금을 받은 학생들 중에서
꼭 노벨상 수상자가 나오면 좋겠다.
그런 아주 기쁜 포부로
진짜 너무 행복하겠다.
진짜 요청이 진짜 많았어요.
윤하님 좀 모셨으면 좋겠다.
채널의 그 괴랑 좀 잘 맞는다.
그런 요청이 있었는데
오늘 드디어 성사가 됐습니다.
오늘 또 과학하고 굉장히 밀접한 관련이 있으신
두 분 딱 모셨거든요.
자기소개 좀 부탁드리겠습니다.
윤하님부터
안녕하세요.
저는 과학을 사랑하고
과학 안에서 모든 노래를 할 수 있다고 생각하고 있는
윤하입니다. 반갑습니다.
원래 과학으로 모든 노래를 하려는 생각은 아니었는데
코로나 기점으로
네, 맞습니다.
그렇게 좀 많이 방향성이 잡힌 거죠?
아, 그런 것도 있고
그리고 괴도 오빠가 뭐든지 과학으로
기승전 과학으로 귀가시키는 사람이잖아요.
그럼 내가 컵이 떠올랐어.
그럼 이 컵도 과학이다.
이렇게 되는
과학으로 설명하지 못하는 주제는 없다.
컵과학이죠.
컵도 과학이에요?
컵 이 손잡이 모양 보시면
위상수학 설명할 때 되게 좋은 게
컵이 도는 모양이거든요.
머그컵으로다가 위상수학 비율을 되게 많이 들어요.
그게 뭐예요? 위상수학?
위상수학이 이제 모든 형태가 있는 것들을
단순화시켜서 우주의 모양을 이해하고 싶은
근데 이건 도넛 모양과 똑같아요.
두드려서 이 구멍이 하나 뚫려있어요.
에이, 이거 도넛 모양인 건 나도 알아요.
사람도 도넛입니다.
도넛 모양이지 뭐.
사람도 도넛이에요.
아, 나 뭔지 알 것 같아.
안쪽을 바깥쪽으로 뒤집을 수가 있어요, 우리는.
너무 징그러운데?
왜냐면 실제로 입 안으로 들어오는 게
실제로 그대로 나갈 수 있는 길이 그냥 뚫려있는 거고요.
방금 그 말은 일본 만화에 나올 법한 연식이에요.
일본 만화가 이런 거 되게 좋아해요.
아, 맞아.
왜 그런지 모르겠어.
그리고 괴도 님 소개해 주세요.
부탁드리겠습니다.
네, 안녕하세요.
과학 애호가 괴도입니다.
대한민국에서 가장 유명한 두 과학 커뮤니케이터 분들 모시고
할 수 있는 점에 영광입니다.
제가 강연 때 항상 이야기하거든요.
대한민국에 정말 유명한 과학 커뮤니케이터 두 명 있다.
방송계의 침착맨.
그리고 가요계의 윤하.
두 분은 사실상 과학 커뮤니케이터예요.
과학 커뮤니케이터가 아닌데.
어쩌다가 이렇게.
그래서 저는 오늘 과학 애호가입니다.
너만 과학 커뮤니케이터예요.
그래서 오늘 이렇게 딱 만나게 됐는데
윤하 님이
저랑 좀 좋아하는 분야가 겹치시더라고요.
핫스톤도 한 적이 있었고.
요즘에는 안 하시죠?
요즘에는 안 해요.
포켓몬스터.
포켓몬스터 좋아했죠.
그런 것도 있고.
애니메이션 OST 같은 거 많이 참여하셨고.
네, 많이.
그러면 애니메이션도 좀 어느 정도
섭렵을 하신 편이에요?
최근에는 체인소맨을 너무 재밌게 봤어요.
아, 체인소맨.
체인소맨까지 그냥 싹 달렸는데.
레제편이 정말.
나 그거 안 봤는데.
레제편 안 봤어?
여기서 나오잖아요, 그 투비.
바로 봤어요.
그거 약간 진입장면.
그렇죠.
아니, 왜 여기서 나오냐고.
되게 아플 것 같은데서.
그거 막 여기서 나오는.
막 이런 데도 나오잖아.
나는 정갈하게 나왔으면 좋겠어.
쭉 갈라져서 나올게요.
그렇지, 그렇지.
재밌습니까?
재밌었습니다.
레제편은 정말 캐릭터성이 장난 아니죠.
아니, 레제편 또 언제 보셨어요?
저는 다 봤습니다.
과학 얘기해야 되니까 또.
과학 커뮤니케이터라서
본인이 애니메이션을 좋아하는 것도 있지만
화제작이 있으면 보긴 봐야 돼요.
그렇죠, 그렇죠.
어떤 요소가 있을지 모르니까.
그러면은 귀멸의 칼날, 무한성을 꼭 봐야 된다고
그런 말씀을 좀 하셨었거든요.
혹시 아직 안 보셨어요?
저는 아직 안 봤어요.
야, 너 진짜.
합동 강화 훈련까지는 봤어.
완전 보면서 울어요.
눈물이 근데 전혀 없으신 타입이신가요?
제가 창작물 보고 운 적이 없어요.
아, 진짜요? 완전 티.
노래를 들을 때도 운 적이 없고.
유나 님 노래 들을 때 운 적 있어요.
너무 분위기가 딱 맞아 떨어지면.
노래는 없는 것 같은데.
보면서는 네, 운 적은 많아요.
저는 이제 울 뻔한 게
미녀는 괴로워.
너무 슬프잖아요.
슬프죠, 슬프죠.
아니, 뒤에서 이름 없는 가수로 울고 있다가
기회가 와서 딱 몸이 다 바뀌었는데
거기서 자충우돌 하니까 너무 슬퍼서
아, 참 제 인생이 참 기구하다.
슬프지, 슬퍼.
그리고 신과 함께.
신과 함께.
신과 함께 원해서 엄마가 말을 못 해.
근데 이제 베개를 이렇게 누르잖아요.
너무 잔인해.
너무 슬펐어요.
그거 두 개 정도가 좀 약간
울 뻔했다.
근데 인정, 인정.
슬프다.
괴도 님은 어때요?
저는 잘 울어요.
저는 축하면 울어요.
지금도 조금 울고 있는 거 같아요.
울어봐요.
아니, 진짜로 근데
그래서 슬픈 거를 안 봐.
그리고 슬픈 거 볼 때 무슨 생각을 하냐면
계속 생각해.
계속 저건 가짜야.
근데 약간 이렇게 울 거 아니에요?
음...
우는 거 아니에요?
보면 짠해서 음...
어떻게 우냐면 안 울려고 하거든요.
눈을 막 굴뜨면서?
눈을 막 이렇게 돌려.
왜냐면 이게 눈을 크게 뜨면은
안구에 붙어 있는 눈물이 증발하면서
좀 덜 울 수 있어요.
팁입니다.
그래서 이러다가 이걸 버티고 버티고 버티다가
주르르르르 흘립니다.
그럼 그때부터는 이제 이미 흘렀잖아.
그럼 계속 닦는 거야.
계속 닦아.
그때부터 막 코 붓잖아요.
맞아, 맞아.
너무 슬퍼.
그리고 고등학교 때 아이큐 검사를 했는데
150이 넘으셨다고.
어?
아, 맞아요.
괴도과네요, 괴도과.
저보다 높은데요?
근데 전 재검사 요망이라 뜨던데요?
더 높은가 보다.
이걸로 할 수 없는 두뇌인가 보다.
근데...
근데 이제 낮게 나올까 봐 안 했어요, 재검사.
아니, 왜냐면 이 정도면 재검사 하면은 진짜...
아니, 근데 화면으로 보면 눈이 괴도 눈이에요.
오!
아, 약간...
삼배 같은...
아니, 150...
아이큐 150 눈이야.
눈이, 눈이 맑은 사람들이야.
아니, 묘하게...
세상을 갚고 싶어.
어, 묘하게 괴도 눈이네.
이게 이런 눈이 방송으로 보면은
눈이 크구나, 이렇게 끝나는데
실제로 보잖아요.
딱 마주치면은
메주사처럼 눈을 뭐 뜯고
이렇게 딱 하고, 눈이.
눈에 딱 사로잡혀서.
저는 처음에 괴도님 눈을 한...
괴륜한...
1년간 잘 안 봤어요.
눈을 마주치면 피했어요.
왜냐?
부담스러워.
마주치는 순간 눈을 못 벗어나고.
너무 부담스러워가지고.
진짜 희긴 희어요.
눈 마주치는 순간 이제 못 벗어납니다, 못 벗어나.
알겠지.
요번에 이제 그 앨범이 또 나온다고.
네네, 서브 캐릭터 원이 나옵니다.
서브 캐릭터 원은
네 곡의 리메이크 앨범인데요.
제가 좋아하는 아티스트 분들의
네 곡을 추려서 넣게 되었고.
그럼 곡이 뭐뭐 있는 거예요?
대절범죄라는 곡이 성동기가 됐고요.
그리고 염락, 스카이바운드, 서브 캐릭터
이렇게 네 곡이에요.
리메이크 앨범을 낼 때는
그냥 앨범 낼 때랑 좀 다른 게 있어요?
원곡의 느낌을 잘 유지하면서도
어떻게 내 색깔을 넣을 수 있을까
이런 게 좀 고민이 되기는 하죠.
그럼 더 어렵죠?
훨씬 어려워요.
왜냐하면 기준치가 이미 잡혀있는 상태에서
그게 또 이미 치사하게 먼저 많이 들어가지고
그걸 이제 정답처럼 생각하고 있는 상황에서
이걸 낸다는 게 어렵잖아요.
그런데도 이제 리메이크 앨범을 낸 이유가?
지금까지 제가 22년 동안 활동하면서
리메이크 앨범을 한 번도 낸 적이 없거든요.
첫 번째 리메이크 앨범인데
터치잖아요, 터치.
아, 터치. 그러네, 그러네.
그거는 근데 커버의 느낌이 좀 강하긴 했던 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 제가
단발 시절.
와, 터치가 여기서, 여기서 나와.
지금 타폭도들이 지금 몰려오고 있어요.
아, 그래요? 아, 말하면 안 돼요?
와, 금기를 깼어.
아, 말하면 안 돼?
아니야, 아니야. 말, 말, 괜찮아.
아, 나 그 노래 좋아해, 실제로.
나 가끔씩 검색해서 듣는다.
내가 보석함이 있어요, 노래.
와, 거기에 있다고요?
일본어 버전, 일본어 버전.
일본어 버전.
아, 이걸 옆에서 듣네.
그러면 이제 좀 만족도는 어땠습니까?
저는 가이 쩐다고 봅니다.
꼭 들어보셔야 된다고 생각하고 있어요.
그리고 아마 침투율을 보시는 분들도
좀 좋아하실 거라고 생각해서
꼭 말씀드리고 싶어서 나오기도 했습니다.
과학 관련된 노래가 앞으로도 좀 계속 나올 예정이 있어요?
모든 것은 과학이기 때문에.
사실 하면 다 과학이니까.
이번에도 사실은 염라가 또 굉장히 좋죠?
오, 염라는 과학적으로 어떻게.
여만아트름.
뭐, 여만아트름.
여만아트름 아니에요? 염라.
여만아트름 이러고 있다, 이러시네요.
그러면 이제 과학 노래가 뭐 예를 들어 사건의 지평선이 이제 좀 대표적이죠.
아, 네, 네.
그래서 이제 우주 관련된 노래였는데
그게 사람들이 너무 좋아하니까
사실 이거 예상을 한 건 아니었잖아요.
아, 진짜.
그러면은 좀 약간 그런 거 있을 것 같아요.
나는 한 이 정도 생각했는데 이렇게?
사람들이 훨씬 좋아하네. 그럼 사람들한테 좀 맞춰줘야 되나?
와, 그거 너무 어려운 것 같아요.
중간에 좀 계속 왔다 갔다 하긴 할 것 같아요.
어제 다르고 오늘 달라요, 사실. 막 흔들리기도 하고.
또 회사에서 계속 잠자리 잡힌다고 하거든요. 이렇게 이렇게.
잠자리 잡힌다는 게 뭐예요?
저희 대표님이 최면수를 하시는지
이렇게 너 이거 이거 좋아해 이러면
아, 그런 것 같기도 하고.
근데 또 집에 가서 생각해보면
응, 아니야, 아니야. 나 이거 하고 싶어.
이러면서 계속 조율해 나가는 과정인 것 같아요.
대표님이 계속 이래요.
야, 사건의 지평선 같은 거 하나 더 하자.
백만 번만 했죠, 백만 번.
계속 이래요?
네, 계속 이래요.
이게 잠자리 잡힌다는 거예요?
야, 하얀.
너무 좋아, 이거.
하얀.
있잖아. 지평선 같은 거.
저 이거는 너무 지평선이랑 비슷한 것 같아요.
아니야, 좋아.
너무 좋아, 이거.
야, 이거 너무 히트할 거야.
근데 또 너무 비슷하게 하면
사람들이 그때 같은 느낌을 안 받잖아요, 그렇죠?
그러니까 그게 참 애매해.
성장이 정체되어 있는 건 또 기가 막히게 아시잖아요.
맞아요.
노린 거를 사람들이 알고
아, 뭐야, 노렸네. 재미없네.
약간 이런 게 있으니까.
그리고 또 가수 입장에서 그것 좀 약간 자존심 상하잖아.
아, 그렇죠.
아니, 내가 널 위해서 했잖아.
네가 이거 좋아한다 해서 내가 이거 했잖아.
근데 왜 하려고 하는 거야? 이런 거 있긴 있죠.
근데 윤하 님은 자기 길 가는 사람이에요, 제가 봤을 때.
왜냐하면 사건의 지평선을 지금 우리가 엄청나게 히트를 했기 때문에 잊고 있는데
사실 나왔을 때는 잘 몰랐어요, 사람들이.
역주행을 했거든요.
맞아요.
근데 저는 사실은 대박 날 거라고 완전 예측했어요.
그래요?
말도 안 되게 좋은데 왜 안 듣는 거야, 도대체?
화가 날 정도로, 진짜.
근데 보세요.
정말로 자기 길을 안 가고 대중의 눈치를 보면 사건의 지평선이라는 제목을 못 붙여요.
그리고 곡 안에 사건의 지평선 너머로라는 가사가 들어가잖아요.
이거는 사실은 일반적으로 누구도 안 쓰는 단어예요.
과학계에서만 쓰는 단어란 말이에요.
그것도 심지어 천문학에서 가장 핫한 천체에 있는 거니까.
만약에 눈치를 봤다면 절대 가사에 이걸 넣었으면 안 돼.
근데 눈치를 안 봤기 때문에 제목에 박은 겁니다, 사건의 지평선.
눈치 안 본 거 맞아요?
안 본 거예요.
저 지금 처음 알았어요.
안 본 거야.
예를 들어 딱 들었을 때 이게 무슨 곡인지를 감히 오는 제목이어서 눌러볼 거 아니야.
근데 사건의 지평선이래, 제목이.
이거는 기본적으로 기존의 팬들이나 아는 사람들이 유나의 곡이라고 생각을 못 할 정도입니다.
근데 그 길을 간 거야.
딱 보니까 노래가 너무 좋잖아.
그러다 결국 역주행을 해서 어쩌면 본인의 길을 갔는데
그 본인의 뚝심이 그냥 대중을 흔든 거예요.
유나님의 뚝심이 대단하다?
유나의 뚝배기.
저는 사실 제목을 사건의 지평선으로 넣은 것 자체가
아, 이거는 그냥 말하려고 넣은 제목이다.
이거는 진짜 눈치를 안 보는구나.
그래서 눈치 안 보는 걸로는 진짜 유나님이 탑입니다, 제가 봤을 때.
앞으로도 그래야 돼.
시대적인 것도 많이 도와준 것 같아요.
그때 다들 집에 갇혀 있을 때잖아요.
그러다 보니까 자연을 되게 동경하고 별 얘기.
사실 과학에 대해서.
궁금할 일이 살면서 현생이 너무 바쁘니까
없다가 그때 다 같이 심심해진 상황이니까
그런 공감대도 형성이 되었던 것 같고 여러모로 운이 좋았던 것 같아요.
실제로 코로나 때 과학 관련된 영상들을 많이 보시다가
관심이 생기셔서 이런 노래가 나온 건데
이해가 굉장히 잘 됐나 봐요. 아이큐가 좀 높으셔서 그런가?
아니요. 그냥 계속 보다가 너무 졸려서 자고 다시 일어나서 보고
근데 만날 사람이 없잖아요.
근데 이제 그게 가사를 녹이려면 어느 정도는 본인이 얕게라도 이해를 해야 되잖아요.
근데 그게 이제 계속 보다 보니까 이해가 되고 했나 봐요.
한 번에 되지는 않았어요. 과학 채널 계속 틀어놨거든요.
그래서 그때 당시에 현존하는 한국 과학 채널 다 봤을 거예요, 아마.
그때 그럼 궤도님을 알았어요?
네, 네. 궤도님이 어디에나 나와요.
그냥 무슨 키워드를 써도 궤도님이 계속 나오고 그거에 대해서 다 이미 설명을 했어.
처음에는 아이씨, 뭐야? 이렇게 넘겼는데.
아이씨.
다 있으니까 포기하고 보게 된.
그때가 한창 안 하는 거 뭐 있지 찾아다닐 때예요.
이거 혹시 안 하는 거 뭐 있지?
검색해서 안 나온다, 내가 한다. 그랬던 시절이죠.
그럼 이제는 없어요?
다 다르죠.
지금도 기존은 똑같아요. 다른 사람이 못 하는 게 뭐가 있나.
그거를 찾아다닌 거죠.
그럼 나는 뭘 해야 될까?
억과, 억과.
억과는 사실 제가 제일 큰 거 같아요.
억지 과.
억지 과 뭔지 알아요? 억지 과.
억지로 이것도 과학이죠, 하는 거.
어떻게든 과학을 하나라도 더 전하는 거예요.
저한테 완전 기조이기 때문에.
진짜 대단한 사람이에요.
철칙, 철칙.
그래서 유나 님은 에피소드 같은 거 들으면 가서 안 하셨으면 이런 거 호기심이 많으시니까 이런 학문 쪽으로 좀 갔을 것 같기도 하거든요.
어렸을 때 막.
어렸을 때요?
예를 들면.
공부 너무 싫었어요.
그때는 재미가 없었나 봐요?
네, 너무 졸리고. 수학 막 4점 이랬거든요.
4점?
네, 검정고시 때 벼락치기로 미친 듯이 해가지고.
그때 4점 맞았잖아요. 궤도가 사람 치고 많았을 거예요.
그때 이제 고등학교 다닐 때 과학고 다녔잖아요.
아니, 제가 만약에 어릴 때 만났잖아요. 공부했을 수도 있어요. 유나 님.
어릴 때 만났잖아요. 그러면.
참 잘 잡았어요.
사실 당신도 마찬가지야.
네? 뭘?
당신, 내가 볼 때 어릴 때 나 만났잖아요. 당신도 공부했어요.
왜냐면 이렇게 재능 있는 사람들을 이 학문의 길로 이끄는 역할을 저는 초등학교, 중학교, 고등학교 때부터 했습니다.
아이, 왜 지 공부하는데 바쁘지 뭐.
왜냐면 진짜. 어? 이걸 이렇게 한다고?
이거를 왜 공부를 안 하지?
막 계속 굵게 박수 치면서.
정말. 아니, 왜냐면 둘 다 재능이 있거든. 진짜로.
탐구하는 능력이 일단 있어요. 그러니까 뭘 보면 집요하게 파고들어가지고 뭔가를 찾아내.
두 분 다 마찬가지입니다.
나는 안 그런다. 나는.
침착맨도 거의 변태적으로 그걸 잘해요. 유나 님도 탐구정신이 장난 아니에요.
끝까지 공부하고 끝까지 뭔가 연구하고.
근데 안 했죠.
근데 4점 받았을 때 생각하셨어요? 아, 노래해야겠다.
4점.
수학 4점 딱 받고. 아.
딴 거 해야겠는데.
아, 이미 그때는 노래를 하고 싶었던.
아, 이미 노래하고 있을 때요?
네. 노래하고 싶었던 생각을 이걸로 가득 차서 공부가 눈에 안 들어올 때였어요.
그러니까 선 노래해서 이거를 신경을 안 써서 4점이 나온 거구나.
아, 노래를 너무 잘하니까.
근데 치고는 어떻게 4점이 나와요?
노래를 오히려 못했으면 공부했을 수도 있는데.
잘하는 게 하나 있어 보니까 아, 아쉬운 거죠. 과학계에서는 좀.
하고 싶은 거에 되게 집중하는 스타일인 것 같긴 해요.
아, 그러면은 집에서는 노래할 때 지원을 많이 해주시는 편이에요?
아니면은.
아, 절대 안.
4점을 어떻게든 14점까지는 올려보자 라고 하는 그런 집 분위기였어요.
공부를 해라 쪽이었고요.
아, 14점까지를 좀 올려봐라.
네. 그리고 오디션 본다고 하니까 아빠는 저보고 음치라고 했었거든요.
어?
음치.
너는 음치라 가수는 안 돼. 그래서.
잠자리 돌렸구나. 아버지가.
야, 글러 가지 마.
야, 여기 14점 받으면 다음에 24점 받으면.
야, 일로 와. 자꾸 잠자리 돌리는데 안 들었구나.
오디션 막 보러 다니고.
아버님이 노래를 잘 부르시나?
아, 아빠 아직도 좀 풍부한 게 어렸을 때 저한테 난 그래도 최강창민 정도 할 수 있다고.
내 기준이 최강창민이야. 내 기준이 최강창민이야.
몰라요.
최강창민이 왜 나와.
근데 그때가.
그러니까 아버지가 인정한 사람인가봐.
최강창민.
최강, 최강이잖아.
최강이라서.
최강.
그때 막 되게 이렇게 번개머리하고 왜 라이제이션이었나?
노래 잘하시니까, 최강창민.
그때쯤이었거든요. 그때 TV를 보다가 우연히 와! 하면서 최강창민 씨가 샤워팅을 하고 있었는데 나는 최강창민 정도는 할 수 있을 것 같아요.
갑자기 아무도 안 물어봤는데.
갑자기.
유나님 물어보셨어요?
전혀 안 물어봤어요.
근데 갑자기 쇼파에서 보시다가 나는 최강창민 정도는 할 수 있을 것 같아.
노래를 하는 것도 그런 노래를 한 적이 없는데.
근데 이제 집에서 이제 반대를 했는데도 오디션을 보러 다니신 거예요? 개인적으로?
네. 그때 제가 H.O.T 오빠들 너무 좋아해서 정말 혀니 두라였거든요. 안치련 마누라.
닉네임이요?
네. 혀니 두라. 그래서 오디션 많이 보고 보아 언니도 너무 좋아했어가지고 그런 가수가 되고 싶었었나 봐요.
내 사촌 형이 강타님하고 같은 고등학교여가지고 1년 선배여서.
강타님이 등교를 하면은 가끔씩 할 거 아니에요. 그럼 이제 복도에 이제 그 가가지고 반 있죠. 그래서 사진 찍어 왔어요.
오 난리 난 거.
안치련 씨를 찍어 왔어요.
아니 저 친한 형도 같은 학교인데 너무 놀랬대요. 데뷔했을 때. 너무 조용한 친구였어가지고.
모범생이었다고.
그리고 이제 이름도 약간 안칠현이잖아. 안쳐. 근데 갑자기 강타로 나오니까 너무 반대가 돼서.
그러네.
그러니까 너무 놀랬어요. 그 형이.
제모해네.
안치려고 했는데.
안쳐 안쳐.
야 안쳐 안쳐.
갑자기 강타니까.
야 나 안친 거야.
이 형 너무 놀래갖고.
그러네.
야.
와 이거 좋았다.
안칠현이 어떻게 강타가 됐지 이러면서. 근데 되게 조용하고 너무 착한 분이었더라고요.
순수함이 음악에서도 느껴졌으니까.
진짜 진짜.
빛 이런 거.
노래 너무 잘해.
북극성.
어 북극성 그쵸.
아 계도 님이 말해 뭐예요. 그 현이 마누라 님이 더 잘 아시겠지.
격하셨고.
그러네.
그럼 현이 마누라 님은 안치련 님에 관련돼서 눈물을 흘린 적 있나요?
너무 좋아서 눈물 흘린 적 많죠.
아 좋아서? 슬퍼서도 있나요?
슬퍼서도 있죠. 우리 오빠가 너무 힘들어할 때.
그때 막 감정 접근. 집에서 야 하야 이거 시험지 이거 4점 뭐냐.
근데 아 오빠가 너무 슬프고 안타깝고.
그쵸. 그런 상황인 거죠.
아빠는 주로 3단 우산으로.
훈육.
3단이 좋다. 3단이 좋다.
그 당시에는 매질이 있었어요.
아 그쵸. 매질이.
가정 내 매질이 있었어.
악만의 시대였어.
근데 3단이면 되게 합리적인 게.
3단은 잘 부서집니다.
그럼 쿠션이 있어.
네. 1단이 제일 아파요. 1단이 제일 강력하고.
아 그쵸.
왜냐면 단이 올라갈수록 구조가 복잡해지기 때문에 고장이 잘 나.
그래서 3단으로 친다는 건 내구도가 없는 걸로 치는 거야.
아 그쵸.
비주얼 정도로만.
그쵸. 그쵸.
위해를 가하는.
3단은 괜찮네.
매질은 왜 강하셨어요?
공부를 안 하니까.
공부를 안 하고.
이게 모든 정황이 맞아떨어지네. 음악 한다고 해서 하지 마라.
너 그쪽이 아니다. 근데 공부를 계속 안 하고.
4점의 지평선.
4점이야. 4점.
그럼 아빠는 그런 사건을 보면 볼수록 아 얘를 잘 잠자리 돌려가지고 이쪽으로 데리고 와야겠다는 생각을 더 하셨겠다.
사회에 도움이 되는 사람으로 커야 되는데 벌썩으로 만들어서 대학을 가고 나서 가수를 하고 싶으면 시켜주겠다.
아 그런 타협안까지.
네. 그렇지만.
아 난 필요 없다. 난 현이 마누라다.
그냥 가서 일단 붙었어요.
어떻게 하다가 보니까 데모테이프에 일본까지 가게 돼서 그게 발탁되면서
아빠한테 통보를 했죠.
나는 일본 간다.
내가 일본에서 붙었어.
이렇게 하니까.
네가 지금 미쳤구나. 무슨 소리를 하고 있는 거니.
3단 주사 꺼냈어요?
3단 주사 꺼냈죠.
야. 네가 최강창민이야?
그렇죠.
일본을 왜 가?
최강창민은 아닌데. 그렇죠?
돈 줘. 이렇게 해서.
그래서 최소한 받아서 간 거예요?
네네. 5천 원 주셔가지고.
5천 원 주셨어요?
회전초밥집에서 한 끼에 다 썼어요.
아 그걸 또 계획성 없이 썼어요?
그렇게 비쌀 줄 몰랐어요.
아.
물가가 또 그때.
너무 그때 비쌌어요.
맞아 맞아.
엔고였기 때문에.
아버지가 좀 걱정하실 만하다.
아 걱정하시나요?
약간 기분파네.
아 나는 누구? 현이 마누라. 이제 그것만 파는 거야.
간다. 현이를 만나러 간다.
간다. 어? 나 배고파? 회전초밥.
왜냐면 라면을 먹어야 되는데 회전초밥으로 간 거 자체가 과감한데.
글을 못 읽으니까 접시 100엔 이렇게 써 있잖아요.
그러면 아 내가 10개 먹으면 1,000엔 정도 되려나?
접시마다 가격이 다르잖아.
그렇죠. 가격이 더 싼 것도 있겠지 하고 갔다가 몰랐죠. 색이 막 그렇게 많은지.
다 먹었는데 탕진했네.
그럼 일본어는 어떻게 읽히셨어요?
일본어는 가서 거기에 소속사가 생긴 거예요.
일본 스태프분들하고 같이 있고.
그리고 현지에서 영어로 일본어를 가르쳐주는 데를 갔는데.
저는 영어도 못하는데 한 장 하는 거죠.
서로 한 장 하는 거예요.
아 그러네.
그렇게 뭔가 체득하는 듯이 시작을 하게 됐어요.
연습 끝나고 이제 따로 공부도 하시고요?
공부를 잘 안 했긴 해요.
일본어 또 안 했어요?
아니 보통 가면 본인이 다 급해서 막 한대.
왜냐면 본인이 너무 답답하니까.
그래서 집에 오면 단어 같은 거 외우고 한다고 했는데 그거 안 했어요?
아 단어는 그래도 조금 외웠어요. 하루에 10개씩.
근데 뭐 택도 없죠. 10개 가지고.
그래서 저는 대학에 가서 공부를 했어요.
아이큐 검사 다시 받으시는 것도.
그래서 안 받았어요.
아니다. 오히려 아이큐가 높은 거다.
공부를 안 했는데 일본어를 습득을 했잖아.
어학에 좀 재능이 있으신가 보다.
재능이 있는 거죠.
그쵸?
그러니까 이게 머리가 좋고 본인이 꽂히면 딱 하니까.
어렸을 때 설사 4점을 받았다고 하더라도.
이게 지금은 쌓인 게 많잖아요.
이게 사실 어렸을 때 공부랑 상관이 없는 것 같으신데.
그러니까 4점을 받고 이렇게 될 수 있다라는 거는.
이거는 사실은 얼마나 우리가 그 점수가 크게 중요하지 않은가.
그러니까 그게 너무.
숫자에 그게.
인생에서는 전혀 중요한 게 아니라는 거예요.
아 중요하지 않습니까?
전혀 중요하지 않아요.
그러니까 공부에 너무 얽매일 필요 없어요.
그냥 내가 뭘 좋아하는가.
그 마음이 있는가.
근데 일본 가셔가지고 잘 모를 거 아니에요.
일본어도 모르고.
만약에 업체가 사기야.
그럴 수도 있잖아요.
그런 위험도 있었을 거 아니에요.
너무 운이 좋았죠.
너무 운이 좋게.
그런 일이 하나도 없었어요.
데뷔시켜준다고 해서 막 농장 데려가면서.
농장에서 이러고.
아 그 처음 갔을 때.
너무 운이 좋게 소니 뮤직에서.
그걸 데려가 주셔가지고.
아 소니.
네.
소니는 뭐 다 아는 이름이니까.
그러니까요.
제가 막 그때 cdp 카세트 이런 거 있었잖아요.
다 소니였으니까.
오 그 소니가 여기야?
하면서 들어갔던 기억이에요.
그러면 일본에서는 몇 년 정도 준비하시다가 바로 데뷔를 하신 거예요?
일본에서 금방 데뷔했어요.
데뷔는 1년 만에 했고.
근데 처음 나왔을 때는 완전 폭삭 망했고.
그래도 무명기 길지 않았어요.
뒤에 바로 블리츠 타이어 그게 확정이 되면서.
맞아 맞아.
2005년도였으니까 한 데뷔하고 1년 정도 만에.
그럼 거기서는 푸쉬를 해주는 신인이었어요?
어 그랬던 것 같아요.
그 한류 열풍이 있으니까.
아 싹수가 있다.
싹수가 있다.
아 그런 건가?
그때 당시 이제 데뷔할 때쯤 일본어가 이제 올라왔겠네요.
이제 그래도 자기소개를 할 수 있을 정도.
그리고 어디 나가서 쇼 같은데 초대되면 말을 해야 될 거 아니에요.
그쵸 그쵸.
근데 이제 너무 못하면 안 되잖아요.
못 알아듣는 말이 80%죠 사실.
뭐 어쩌고 저쩌고 저쩌고 데스까? 이러면은 음 하잇 뭐 이런.
웃어.
한 번 쉬는구나.
웃어야 돼.
그게 포인트구나.
아리가또.
이렇게 하면은 그냥 외노자 불쌍하게 쳐다보면서.
아 외노자.
이거 치지직 여기 인터넷 방송에서도 외노자가 있어요.
오.
일본 사람들이 와서 하거나 다른 나라 사람들이 와서.
그렇구나.
네.
다른 나라 사람이 와서 이제 하는 경우가 있는데 그때 당시는 유난히
외노자였고 그런 건 없었어요.
난 일본 예능 같은 거 보면은 거기 개인들이 있잖아요.
네네네.
되게 장난이 심하잖아요.
그런 거는 힘들진 않아요?
네.
잘 못 알아들으니까.
아 오히려.
아.
잘 몰랐던 거 같아.
아니 막 때리고 이런다는 걸 내가 인터넷 커뮤니티 같은 데서 봤
거든요.
오.
때리는 뭔가 그 개그가 있대.
아 맞아요.
패널들이.
머리 때리고 막 이런 거 있는데.
근데 또 미성년에 대한 보호가 되게 그때 가겠어요.
아.
근데 저는 완전 미성년자고 16살 이러니까.
아하.
아기를 때리기는 어려우니까.
약간 열애구나.
그래도.
유난히 나가있어.
자.
맞아요.
그러고 있는데.
빡.
제가 맞지는 않았다.
아.
그러면은 성인 할 때도 있었을 거 아니에요.
성인 때 이제 기가 막히게 한국으로 와 가지고.
아하.
안 맞으면.
탈출.
맞을까 봐 탈출.
개인들이 다 기다리고 있었는데.
야.
이제 성인만 돼봐라.
내가 쟤는 성인 되면 한 번 때려야겠다.
이제 입맞다시고 있는데 한국으로.
사양하라.
이렇게.
아하.
야.
한 번도 못 때리고 그냥 끝났네.
그러면 일본에도 이제 왔다 갔다는 그래도 하셨을 거예요.
네.
한동안은 왔다 갔다 했는데 요즘에는 한국에서만 활동을 하게 된 것 같아요.
똑같은 곡을 다른 언어로 내는 건 괜찮은데 일본은 항상 오리지널 곡을 내야 되는 그게 있어서 쉽지 않더라고요.
체력적으로.
일본은 그 일본으로 된 오리지널이 있어야 돼?
사건의 지평선이 잘 됐다고 해서.
번환을 하면.
사건의 지평선 번환도 있어야 되지만 일본 내에서 일본 작가들 하고 또 그만의 브랜드를 또 해야 돼서 사실은 이중생활을 하는 거나 다름이 없거든요.
일을 두 배로 하는 거구나.
네.
그쪽 시스템에서의 곡이 있어야 되는구나.
맞아요.
아니면 일본에 신경 쓰던가.
네.
일을 두 배로 하던가.
그러면 이거 다시 또 리메이크 앨범으로 돌아와 보면은 그냥 개인적으로 좀 추천하는 곡이 있다면?
저는 서브 캐릭터라는 곡이 좀 되게 마음이 많이 가요.
네.
서브 캐릭터.
이 앨범의 제목이 되기도 했고 조현의 입장에서의 주인공을 보면서 부러워하는 그런 얘기거든요.
근데 그 원곡을 위즈씨가 리릭비디오로.
네.
리릭비디오로 발매를 하셨는데 리릭비디오에 주인공으로 추정되는 여성과 조현으로 추정되는 핑크머리 여성이 나와요.
근데 주연 쪽에 포커싱이 맞춰진 채로 리릭비디오가 시작이 되다가 2절에서 이게 이렇게 스위칭 되거든요.
아.
와 거기서 소름이 쫙 돋으면서 와 그렇지 이게 다 상대적인 거지.
음.
이런 감동이 있었어요.
모두가 다 모두의 삶의 주인공인 거잖아요.
말씀 너무 좋지만 계두님 갑자기 생각이 들어가지고요.
네.
제가 한 거 있거든요.
계두 주제.
오 네 네.
뼈개침.
거기에 댓글에 자꾸 일본 개닌 닮았다고.
갑자기.
아니 아니 계두를 보니까 죄송해요.
말씀하시다가.
아니요 아니요 아니요.
중간부터는 아 개닌 닮았다는 얘기가.
아니 그러니까 원래 촬영을 안 하기로 했었어가지고.
셋이 진짜 그냥 놀러 가는 거였어가지고.
어.
근데 또 파마를 한 지 너무 오래 돼갖고 머리가 완전 다 펴진 거예요.
완전 풀린 상태고.
근데 이제 촬영을 안 한다 그래갖고 진짜 편하게 막 얄랄라 얼굴도 막 이상하게 해서 갔는데.
촬영을 해야 된다고 하니까.
상황이 어쩔 수가 없다.
뭐라도 해야 되니까.
왜냐면 내가 이제 머리 어떻게 만들었는지 모르겠는 거야.
그때 머리가 예쁘게 이렇게.
유명한 분이에요?
모르겠어요.
요즘 일본 연예계는 잘 모르시죠?
네.
몰라요.
바나나맨 히무라.
되게 유명한 분.
네.
아무튼 고맙습니다.
그죠?
뭐라도 고맙죠.
예.
일본 가면 광고에 수십 번 나오신대요.
아 그래요?
내가 지나가다가 얼굴이 좀 익숙하게 본 거 같으면 그런 것 같아요.
감사한 일 있죠.
또 이제 잘나가시는 분.
광고도 많이 하시는 분이니까.
그래서 사실 유나님 모시고 이런저런 재밌는 얘기를 많이 나눴는데 또 계도님이 또 유나님 모신다고 해가지고 특강을 또 준비를 해 주셨어요.
이야.
아니 어제 막 새벽까지 하시던데.
이거 누려도 될까요?
아니 진짜로 제가.
히무라님.
준비를 정말.
히무라의 작은 동생.
아니 이러면 또 히무라 된다니까.
히무라의.
아 안돼 안돼.
어쨌든 들어가기 전에.
네.
사실 이번 특강 준비를 정말 열심히 했거든요.
그리고 원래는 이제 또 우리 유나님 얘기도 좀 많이 하려고 자료에 많이 넣어놨는데 근데 시간이 사실은 해보니까 무제한으로 들어가더라고요.
그래갖고 안 되겠다 싶어서 거의 3분의 2 정도를 아예 쳐내고 오늘은 사실 유나님의 히트작 중에 하나에 혜성에 좀 초점을 맞춰가지고 혜성처럼 등장했어요.
혜성이란 곡으로 굉장한 임팩트를 줬고 사실은 그것 때문에 지금의 유나가 있다고 해도 과언이 아니거든요.
단발 유나.
네.
그래갖고 혜성이라는 곡이 있었는데 나중에 살별이라는 곡이 또 나옵니다.
근데 이게 혜성의 순우리말이거든요.
저는 이 살별이라는 곡은 과연 어떤 느낌일까.
제가 느낀 거는 과거의 유나는 우리가 알던 그 혜성이었어요.
그러니까 강력한 임팩트를 주고 하염없이 날아다니며 우리가 봤을 때는 정말 아름답게 보이는 그런 혜성이었는데.
지금의 살별은 충분한 시간이 지나고 과거의 혜성과 어떻게 바뀌었을까.
그래서 개인적으로 일단 그 살별을 한번 라이브로 좀 청해보고 오늘의 특강을 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
살별 한번 들어보시죠.
2026년이니까 C2026YH로 렛츠고!
C2026YH 발견으로 태어날 테니 이렇게만 적을래
깨지고 부딪쳐도 나가는 길은 자질없어
가끔 외롭긴 해도
저 멀리 푸른 점에 잘 살고 있는 사람들은
끝없이 여길 동영향했지
어린 작가 돌덩이에 지나기 위해
이걸 궤도 씨가 좋아해요.
궤도에 존재하는 이유가 나서.
네.
궤도 전에 오르트그룸에서 궤도를 벗어나고 싶어라는 대목이 있습니다.
근데 우주 관련된 건 궤도라는 거가 좀.
빠지기 쉽지 않아.
빠지기 쉽지 않잖아요.
자주 들어갈 수밖에 없잖아요.
근데 그때는 벗어나고 싶어였는데 존재하는 이유가 나오니까 긍정적으로.
그래갖고 이건 감동이다.
이름을 잘 짰는데.
잘 졌어.
엄청 서운하다 하셨잖아요.
오르트그룸 때.
그래서 준비했잖아요.
그러니까.
이거 너무 좋아요 진짜.
일단은 제가 우리 유나 님 모시고.
이 얘기 안 할 수가 없어서.
어.
한국장학재단에 1억 원을 기부하면서 푸른등대 가수 유나 기부장학금을 만들었습니다.
아마 이거 기초과학하시는 분들은 지원을 지금 받는 분이 계실 거예요.
그래서 이게 기사가 좀 떴는데 생각보다 많은 분들이 몰라.
이거 대단한 일이에요.
이거는 그냥 기부를 한다는 개념이 아니라 내가 앞으로 이 기부라는 행위를 지속적으로 이어가겠다.
왜냐면 장학금이 만들어진 거예요.
그럼 이게 쌓이면 앞으로 수십 년간 정말 많은 기초과학을 하시는 과학자들이 이제 이거의 혜택을 받는 거죠.
그러니까 너무 멋진 일이고.
박수 한 번.
네.
진짜.
와.
대단하다.
전현희 마누라.
사점소녀가.
푸른등대.
공부를 내가 하기 싫어서.
어.
공부하기 싫어서.
너희는 해라.
공부를 짬뽕.
내가 그렇게 하기 싫었던 공부 너희는 해라.
왜냐면 이게 과학계에 기부하기가 쉽지가 않아요.
과학계에 기부하는 건 정말 1도 혜택이 없어.
예를 들어 다른 쪽에 기부를 하면.
혜택이 있어요.
있는 경우가 있어요.
아 그래요.
의료계 어디.
아 본인한테.
네.
왜냐하면 기부자에게 여러 가지 혜택들이 주어지는 경우가 있습니다.
그런데 과학계는 뭐 어떻게 할 거야.
신제품을 뭐 줘.
애매하잖아.
그렇지.
그러니까 과학계에 기부한다는 건 진짜 본인은 어떠한 혜택도 받지
않겠다.
온리 먼 미래 인류한테 돈을 내는 거거든요.
이런 경우가 잘 없어요.
이거는 정말 대단한 일이고.
이거는 뭐 어떤 거예요.
장학금이라는 게 어디에 쓰이는 거예요.
대학생들의 생활 장학금으로 나가는 부분인데요.
저의 하나의 꿈이 있다면 유나 기부 장학금에서 생활 장학금을 받은 학생들
중에서 꼭 노벨상 수상자가 나오고 싶겠다.
그런 아주 깊은 포부로.
진짜 너무 행복하겠다.
대단하십니다.
사실 유나 님하고 엄마는 공통점 이 자기는 공부 안 했지만 너는 해라.
그리고 전폭 지원.
전폭 지원.
정보를 알아보고 지원하고.
그거의 완성은 뭔지 알아요 갈구는 거야.
야 왜 이렇게 세졌는데 못 해.
이번 학기 성적이 왜 그래.
2년에 한 번씩.
그럴 생각이 있으세요
수혜자들 모아놓고.
모아놓고 중위권에 뭐 계신 분들 성적표 지금 뜯어보겠습니다 해서
왜 지원을 해드렸는데 왜 점수가 왜 더 떨어졌죠 이렇게 엄마처럼
할 거예요
그 두 번째 재지원을 하시는 분들 한테는 좀 그런 얘기도 해야겠죠
.
왜냐하면 다른 분에게 갈 수 있는 게 간 거니까 기회니까.
그렇죠.
그래도 좋겠다.
그러니까.
제가 지금 유나를 만나는 거잖아요 .
사실 뭐 욕먹더라도 와 유나다.
그럼 3단 우산 챙겨가요.
요즘 그러면 큰일 나니까 세워만 둘게요.
세워만.
제가 맞았던 3단 우산입니다.
참고만 하시라고요.
그렇게 알겠습니다.
이게 정말 대단한 일이라는 걸 제가 좀 말씀드리고 싶어갖고 이걸 좀
말씀드리고 그리고 이제 다음으로 한 번 가보면 유나 님이 굉장히 많은
음원들을 발매를 했고 또 특히나 이제 그 theory 시리즈를 보면 정말
하나의 거대한 서사시다 이런 식으로 우주 관련된 단어들이 굉장히
많이 들어간 노래들이 있고 근데 단순히 그냥 단어만 쓰는 걸 넘어서
이것들을 모아서 거의 기승전결의 어떤 스토리텔링이 가능합니다.
사실은 이것들을 하나로 쫙 엮어서 하나의 과학특강 스토리를 만들어
보려고 예전에 생각을 했는데 시간 제한이 있어갖고 오늘은 그렇게
는 하지 못하고
이걸 다 엮을 수가 있어요
일단은 짜놓은 게 있어요.
여기서 한 13곡 정도를 뽑아가지고 흐름을 만들어 놓은 게 있습니다.
이 우주의 모든 시작과 끝에 대한 이야기를 했는데.
근데 이거 시간전이 있어갖고 한 3분의 2가량을 쳐냈고요.
오늘은 무료 시간 지킬 겁니다.
그래서 이번에는 좀 테마를 하나로 잡아서 이제 간단하게.
그래서 제목은 떠도는 파편의 과학으로 잡았습니다.
떠도는다고?
네.
우리는 어디서 왔고 어디로 가는가 처음으로 해서 가장 중요한 질문인데요.
여기서 조금 더 구체적으로 들어가서 우리를 방문하는 그들은 어디서 왔고
어디로 가는가에 대한 이야기를 해보려고 합니다.
그래서 오늘은 해성에 대한 이야기가 주가 될 거고요.
그래서 해성.
이게 이제 일본에서 정말 굉장히 사랑을 받았던 이것 때문에 오리콘의 해성이라는 별명이 생기셨죠.
해성처럼 등장한 유나님의 인기곡이고요.
이 엄청난 인기가 만들어지게 된 계기가 어쩌면 해성이 아닐까.
그래서 오늘은 해성이란 무엇인가.
저 사진 진짜 멋있네요.
진짜 멋있죠.
근데 저 사진은 오늘 자료에서 가장 안 예쁜 사진입니다.
오늘 좀 기대를 많이 해주세요.
예쁜 해성들이 많군요.
예쁜 걸 많이 볼 수 있고요.
근데 해성이라는 거.
해성이라는 거 느낌 어떠세요?
해성 딱 들었을 때.
저는 좀 아래로 떨어지잖아요.
좀 불길해요.
아래로 떨어지죠.
진짜로?
와.
위로 가야지.
오.
기세가.
기세로 가야 되는데.
아니 근데 무조건 떨어지진 않아요.
방향이.
히이 이렇게 하잖아요.
오장원의 지는 별.
뭐 이런 거.
아냐 아냐 아냐.
유성 말씀하시는 거 같은데.
오늘 이것도 제가 정리해드릴게요.
그래요?
별똥별.
저런 거 아니에요?
유성하고 해성하고 다른 거예요?
달라요.
해성은 심지어 아래로 떨어지는 것도 있고 위로 솟구치는 것도
있고 정말 수직으로 떨어지는 것도 있고 방향에 따라 다릅니다.
오 그래요?
네.
그리고 이게 해성 그 자체로 굉장히 오랫동안 육안으로 관측이 가능할
정도로 굉장히 재미있는 천체예요.
근데 해성 하면 사실 좀 긍정적인 게 많잖아요.
해성처럼 등장한.
맞아요.
이거 사실 우리는 지금 굉장히 파지티브하단 말이에요.
근데 해성은 처음에는 굉장히 불길한 거였어요.
침착맨처럼.
아.
네.
조화로운 태양계가 안정적으로 잘 만들어져 있는데 갑자기 미지의
침입자가 온 거예요.
한 번도 생각해보지 못한.
그러다 보니까 예상치 못한 상황 자체를 모두가 굉장히 반기지 않았
고 해성이 등장하면 굉장히 불길한 재앙의 징조로 봤습니다.
나랑 비슷하네.
고대의 침착맨들이.
그러니까 현대인이지만 교육이 딱 멈춰버리면 고대인과 굉장히
흡사하죠.
맞아.
사실 원시 인류랑 우리 뇌 시냅스 는 그렇게 차이 없거든요.
나는 하늘을 봤는데 평소에 없던 거 나는 싫어.
오.
아우.
막 창 던질 거야.
심지어 어느 정도냐면 로마의 네로 황제가 해성이 나타나잖아요
.
해성 때문에 자신의 위치를 위협할 만한 귀족들을 전부 죽여요.
와.
네.
해성이 나타났다는 건 누군가가 지금 내 자리를 뺏으려고 하는 징조
다.
그러면 씨를 말려야 된다.
뉴 챌린저의 뜻이라고 생각했나 보다.
네.
그래서 그냥 학살을 합니다.
그 정도로 해성이 굉장히 무시무시한 징조였고 그런데 놀라운 건 해성
은 그렇게 불길한 징조가 아니다.
.
해성을 모를 때는 이거를 억지로 연결을 해가지고 말도 안 되는 상상을
해요.
근데 이때 이제 알게 된 거지.
누가 알려줬느냐 결국 과학자입니다.
영국의 천문학자 에드먼드 헨리가 처음으로 해성은 무서운 문제가
아니다라는 것을 이야기해요.
그래서 헨리 해성이구나.
맞아요.
그 유명한 해성의 이름이 바로 에드먼드 헨리의 이름을 딴 겁니다.
그래서 이분이 해성은 불길한 징조 징후 이런 게 아니다.
뭐냐 그냥 일정한 주기로 어딘가를 돌고 있는 천체일 뿐이고 우리가
우리가 궤도만 어느 정도 비슷하게 알아내면 계산해서 언제 돌아올
지를 알 수 있으니까 사실은 저게 그렇게 별 게 아니다.
이게 무슨 뜻이냐 사실 이때 제가 지평자 표기 얘기를 했어요.
우리 모두가 귀신 초자연적인 존재에 대한 두려움을 갖고 있을 때 최고의
퇴마 주문이라고도 하고 그 미지의 존재에 대한 두려움을 지평자 표
게가 없애줬듯이 사람들이 에드먼드 헨리 덕분에 해성에 대한 그런 두려움을
떨치게 됐고.
.
과학이 우리를 위협하는 많은 것들에 대해서 위협을 없애주는 그런 역할
을 합니다.
그리고 헨리는 세상을 떠났어요 .
그 뒤로 세상을 떠나고 17년이 지났습니다.
생전에 예측한 시기가 왔습니다.
분명히 헨리 해성이 다시 돌아올 거다.
그 시기에 사람들은 밤하늘을 가로 지르는 한 줄기의 빛을 관측합니다.
이 에드먼드 헨리의 예측은 정확하게 맞았고요.
딱 그 시기에 돌아온 바로 헨리 해성입니다.
저거요 저거요 네 저 헨리 해성입니다.
와 끝내준다.
몰랐을 때는 저게 우리를 위협하는 징후라고 생각했지만 사실상 딱
등장을 하니까 어 뭐야 헨리 말이 맞았네 별게 아니네 예측대로 되는
구나.
예측한 결과가 나왔다는 거죠.
그래서 에드먼드 헨리 같은 게 업적이 되게 많아요.
수학자이면서 물리학자이면서 기상학자이면서 천문학자이면서
이분이 이제 금성의 태양면 통과를 관측하면서 케플러의 제3법칙 조
하의 법칙을 이용해가지고 지구와 태양까지의 거리를 정확하게 측정
합니다.
또 지구 전역의 지자기 연구를 하면서 나침반의 편차 이런 것도 하기도
해요.
그러니까 정말 대단한 분이.
제가 봤을 때는 아이큐 150 넘었어요.
152 이상 최소.
정말 업적이 많은 분인데 이분이 그 위대한 업적 대신에 헨리 해성
발견자로만 지금 알려져 있어요.
정말 많은 업적들이 가려지는 측면 도 있지만 좋게 생각하면 그만큼
헨리 해성보다 유명한 해성이라는 건 아직도 존재하지 않는다.
대단한 거죠.
그러면 이제 또 유명한 해성들이 뭐가 있냐 한번 보여드릴게요.
예쁘죠.
오 이것도 예뻐요.
뒤에 성운이 보이네요.
말몰 성운인가.
그렇죠 그렇죠.
되게 예쁘게 됐죠.
힐밥 해성이라는 녀석인데 하나 더 보여드릴게요.
이렇게 생겼어요.
너무 예쁘죠.
성운 이쪽도 좀 아세요.
방금 성운이 보였던 거죠.
성운이죠.
그런데 뭐 저도 사실 관측 쪽이 아니라서.
이게 이제 1997년 대해성입니다.
대해성이라고 이름이 붙는 게 뭐냐 면 육안으로 보일 정도로 밝은 해성
그래서 보통 겉보기 등급이 0등급 근처다 그러면 대해성이에요.
그러니까 0등급이라는 건 뭐냐.
6등급이 있고.
1등급이 있어요.
그러면 6등급보다 1등급이 100배 밝다.
그러니까 1등급에서 6으로 숫자가 5가 늘어나면 100배가 어두워지는
거예요.
그럼 이거보다 밝은 게 0등급인 거고 이게 겉보기 등급이 0등급이라는
건 뭐냐.
겉보기 등급과 절대 등급이 있습니다.
지구에서 봤을 때 얼마나 밝은가 이게 겉보기 등급이고 절대 등급
은 별이 지구로부터 18색 거리에 있을 때를 가정해서 밝기를 측정
한 거예요.
18색이면 얼마나.
10파색.
이 파색이 사실 좀 어려운 단위이긴 해요.
파색이 각도로 거리를 나타내는 거 거든요.
그래서 1각초의 시차를 의미하는데 다들 욕을 하고 계신데.
10파색.
욕은 아닙니다.
어쨌든 좀 복잡한데 이거를 그럼 우리가 잘 아는 킬로미터로 환산
을 하면 10파색이 309조 킬로미터.
어마어마한 거리죠.
모르겠다 그냥.
그러니까 이렇게 보시면 돼요.
태양 밝죠.
태양 맨눈으로 못 보죠.
기아님도 잘 못 보잖아.
그렇죠.
한 번씩 눈 세척해야 된다고 태양 하고 눈싸움해요.
아니.
태양을 이렇게 쭉 봐.
태양을 10파색에 놓으면 절대 등급 이잖아요.
거기서 봤을 때는 4.83 정도 됩니다.
등급이.
근데 겉보기 등급 지구에서 보잖아요 .
마이너스 26.73 등급.
미친 듯이 밝은 거죠.
그러니까 그만큼 태양은 가까이 있어서 더 밝아진 거예요.
그런데 이제 0등급이 겉보기 등급 이면 사실 굉장히 밝은 거거든요
.
1등급 정도면 대해성이라 하는데 사실은 이게 어디까지가 대해성이냐
명확하게 딱 자를 수가 없긴 해요 .
왜냐하면 또 잘 보이는 경우가 있거든 생각보다.
주변 상황에 따라서.
예를 들어 작은 마을에서 어둡고 빛이 별로 없으니까 이럴 때는 그냥
5등급인데도 대해성이라 부르는 경우가 있어요.
워낙 잘 보이니까.
그래서 이제 보통 대해성이 왔다 그러면 1997년의 대해성 이런 식으로
표현을 해요.
2025년의 대해성 이런 식으로.
네.
그래서 잘 보이는 거는 대해성이다 이렇게 하시면 될 것 같고요.
그런데 저 파란색은 뭐예요 항상 궁금했어요.
그게 이거가 이제 오늘 자세히 설명 을 드릴게요.
아 그렇구나.
해성의 핵심이 꼬리입니다 꼬리 .
꼬리가 보통 하나라고 생각하시는데 두 개예요.
지금 이 친구도 두 개의 꼬리가 있는 거죠.
그래서 이 꼬리를 뒤에서 또 설명 을 드릴 거예요.
이온 꼬리라는 애인데.
파란색이 한 꼬리.
네.
하얀색이 한 꼬리.
꼬리가 두 개입니다.
그래서 또 이제 유명한 해성 중에 또 우리나라에서 잘 보였던 애가
있습니다.
네.
네오와이즈 해성이에요.
네오와이즈.
저거는 너무 그건데.
너무 예쁘죠.
정확한데.
네.
그러니까 저렇게 관측이 되는 거야 어두운 데 가면.
여기도 꼬리가 두 개네요.
두 개죠.
네.
그래서 이게 이제 네오와이즈 해성 이고 제가 이제 몸을 담았던 한국
천문연구원에서 직접 이걸 촬영 을 했습니다.
우리나라에서 잘 보였기 때문에 이렇게.
아 이거 우리나라에요.
우리나라에요.
한국 천문연구원에서 촬영한 사진 이고요.
이건 2020년 3월 27일에 발견한 장주기 해성입니다.
그래서 헤일밥 해성이 굉장히 유명 했어요.
그 97년도에.
근데 헤일밥 해성 이후로 가장 유명한 해성이 바로 이 네오와이즈
해성.
그래서 얘가 너무 잘 보였고 어쩌면 굉장히 비교적 최근이라서 이걸
우주정거장에서도 찍었어요.
같은 걸.
네.
보이세요.
저 끝에 저 끝에.
저 끝에.
우주정거장.
예쁘죠.
네.
그래서 우주정거장에서 찍은 게 있는데 제가 이제 뭐 저작권 이슈도
있으니까 영상을 안 가져왔는데 이거는 찾아보시면 영상이 있어요
.
저 네오와이즈 해성이 이렇게 지평 면에서 떠오릅니다.
우주정거장 이동을 하니까.
네.
우주정거장에서 쫙 움직이는데 너무 예뻐요.
그래서 이게 이제 원래 이름은 뭐 우리 윤화님의 살별에서도 처음에
딱 언급을 하죠.
네.
c.
c2022yh.
yh는 윤화인 거죠.
네.
이렇게 명명을 하는 건데 네오와이즈 해성의 정식 명칭이 c2020f3입니다.
그래서 이 해성을 처음 발견한 우주 망원경의 이름이 네오와이즈라는
우주망원경이에요.
헨리가 처음 발견한 해성을 헨리 해성이라 부르듯이.
네.
네오와이즈라는 우주망원경으로 처음 발견했기 때문에 네오와이즈
해성이라고 부르는 거거든요.
그런데 이거를 정식 명칭은 c2020f3입니다.
이 이름을 어떻게 정하느냐.
윤화님도 이제 살별에서 쓰셨듯이 규칙이 있어요.
맨 앞에 c.
이거는 다시 돌아오는 해성의 주기가 200년이 넘는다.
200년이 넘으면 사실 우리가 지금 태어나서 해성을 봤어.
못 봐.
죽기 전까지 못 봐요.
그러니까 윤화님도 c를 붙이셨잖아요.
여러분이 남은 인생에 이렇게 좋은 곡은 또 만날 것이다.
그런 의미가 있는 거죠.
c라는 의미가 있네요.
아니죠.
그만큼.
c.
c를 붙여버렸다는 건 이제 볼 일 없다.
그 정도로.
c를 잘못 부렸네요.
소중하다.
그래서 c를 붙였다는 건 200년이 넘는 주기니까 앞으로 못 볼 거야라는
의미고요.
그보다 짧은 그 주기라서 또 볼 수 있을 가능성이 있다.
그럼 p를 붙입니다.
그리고 이제 바로 뒤에 오는 숫자 와 문자가 발견된 시기와 순서인데
2020이 붙은 건 2020년에 발견된 해성 이고요.
1년을 24달.
그 다음에 구간별로 알파벳을 붙입니다.
그래서 f.
a b c d e f잖아.
그럼 f는 여섯 번째 구간이 되는 거죠.
그래서 결과적으로 니오와이즈 해성의 이름은 2020년 3월 중순 이후에
세 번째로 발견된 장주기 해성이다.
200년이 넘는 주기가 이렇게 보면 될 것 같습니다.
그리고 이제 아까 전에도 이제 18색 하면서 좀 여러 가지 발음에 대한
주의가 있었는데 발음을 주의해야 되는 해성이 또 하나 있습니다.
뭐죠.
얘가 이제 이케아세키 해성.
네.
이케아세키.
응.
네.
익숙한 게 두 가지가 들어가 있죠.
이케아세키라고요.
이케아세키.
네.
c1965s1이라는 해성인데 이것도 이제 대해성이에요.
이케아세키.
진짜 길다 꼬리가.
네.
꼬리가 뭐 꼬리 같지가 않고 파 같아요.
어 그러네요.
거의 너무 찐해서 꼬리 느낌이 아니고 그냥 하나로 그냥 긴 것 같아요
그냥 애초에.
꼬리 느낌이 아니야.
1965년에 이제 관측된 대해성인 거고요.
얘가 보름달보다 무려 60배가 밝습니다.
장난 아니죠.
와.
이게 얼마나 밝으면.
낮에도 보여요.
정오에도 보였대요.
아 그래.
맞아.
낮에도 보이는 거고요.
네.
낮에도 보이는 거야.
우리가 가끔 달이 낮에 보일 때 있잖아요.
네.
너무 밝으니까 정오에도 관측이 되니까 정말 밝고 무려 아까 0등급
이 대해성이잖아요.
네.
마이너스 17등급.
아.
이야.
거의 좀만 더 밝았으면 거의 태양이야.
네.
대단한 거고요.
일본의 천문학자 이케아 가오루와 세키스토무.
같이인 거구나.
네.
이케아 가모루와 세키스토무 이 두 분이 서로 독립적으로 발견한
장주기 해성이다 보니까 두 분의 이름을 같이 넣었어요.
폐허하게.
이게 거의 1000년 동안 보였던 해성 중에 가장 밝은 해성이라고 합니다.
오.
네.
또 이게 스토리가 꽤 있어요.
찐해.
이때 세키스토무가.
세키스토무는 일본 사람이에요?
네.
세키스토무.
세키스토무가 당시 신문에서 이분이 칼럼을 썼는데 미지의 별을
찾아서 라는 칼럼을 연재하고 있었어요.
그러니까 글도 잘 쓰는 분이야.
그런데 칼럼을 연재하면서 미지의 별을 찾아서 하다가 진짜 미지의
해성을 찾은 거죠.
네.
그래서 이케아 세키의 해성을 발견하면서 어 그 칼럼 쓰는 분이 이걸 발견
했어?
네.
굉장히 화제가 됐고 그래서 나중에 또 같은 이름의 색도 등장을 하면서
일본의 천문학 대중화에 큰 기여를 합니다.
세키스토무.
네.
팬도 많아지고.
그러니까 천문학에 관심 있는 분들이 점점 늘어납니다.
그러면 세키 성을 가진 스토무 박사님이에요?
아니 스토무 세키?
모르겠다.
스토무 세키니까 세키스토무니까?
모르겠네요.
스토무 세키일 수도 있어요.
어쨌든 세키니까.
박사님한테 세키.
아니 아니 아니.
박사님한테 세키라니.
아니 이케아 세키.
어?
이케아 세키니까.
해성 자체가.
네.
어차피 해성이 이케아 세키.
세키 박사님.
네.
그리고 또 유명한 게 하나 있습니다.
역사상 가장 긴 꼬리를 갖고 있는 해성.
와.
오늘 가로지른.
이야.
와 이거 멋있다.
하쿠타케.
멋있죠 멋있죠 멋있죠.
이거 멋있다.
이거 멋있어요.
내가 진짜 멋있는 거 뒤에 많다고 그랬죠.
예예.
얘가 이제.
와 이거 멋있다.
하쿠타케 해성인데.
하쿠타케.
1996년 1월 31일에 발견된 해성입니다.
그 C1996B2고요.
200년간 이 하쿠타케 해성보다 지구에 가까이 접근한 해성은 없었다.
그리고 요게 아까 시기적으로 보면요.
헤일밥 해성이랑 좀 비슷한 시기에요.
그렇죠?
97년 96년이니까.
네.
근데 이게 좀 헷갈리기도 하는데 저 꼬리 길이 얼마나 될 것 같아요
.
역사상 가장 긴 꼬리.
이야.
7천미터.
그러니까 우리가 보는 거 말고 진짜 저 우주에서.
9억.
9억 미터.
9억 미터가 뭐야.
근데 비슷해.
저 꼬리의 길이가 5억 7천만 킬로미터.
억 킬로미터요.
올지도 모르겠다.
네.
5억 7천만 킬로미터.
7천만.
예.
대단하죠.
그러니까 이게 어느 정도 긴 거냐면 우리가 주우재 보면서.
주우재님.
이야 키가 왜 이렇게 커.
와 진짜 크다.
하는데 주우재보다 키가 두 배 큰 사람이 등장을 하는 거야.
내가 봤을 때는 주우재는 이 뼈 있잖아요.
뼈가 구멍이 엄청 많을 것 같아.
너무 길어서.
왜냐하면 그걸 다 꽉 차 있는 상태로 뼈가 이어져 있잖아요.
그러면 이게 가동이 안 돼요.
너무 기니까.
새들이 약간 안에가 비어서 날아다니듯이.
아니면 이 뼈랑 뼈 사이가 비어있는 공간이 있을 거예요.
우리는 다 이어져 있잖아요.
그분은 여기가 그냥 대충 근육으로 버티고 있는 부분이 있을 거예요
.
이게 합리적인 게 키가 그렇게 크면 어쨌든 힘을 많이 받잖아요.
걔가 눈도 움푹 꺼졌어.
.
걔가 걔가 보면 퀭해.
그러니까.
어쨌든 그렇게 우재 곱하기 2키 다 무시무시한 거죠.
비난이 아니고 과학 토크예요.
총량의 법칙 총량의 법칙.
그리고 이제 또 재밌는 해상이 하나 나옵니다.
앵케해상.
이건 뭘까.
귀엽다.
맞아요.
얘는 귀여운 해상입니다.
왜 귀엽냐 알려진 밝은 해상 중에서 주기가 가장 짧은 해상.
우리가 아까 말씀드린 그 장주기 .
네.
몇 년이었죠
200년.
네.
200년을 기준으로 이제 장주기 단주기를 나눠요.
200년이 넋면 장 이거보다 좀 짧으면 단.
그런데 단주기 해상은 여기서 더 구분을 세분할 수 있습니다.
10년 미만의 주기면 이런 애들은 목성 궤도를 벗어나지 않거든요
.
네.
이런 애들한테 이름이 이제 앵케형 해상이라는 이름이 붙어요.
앵케형 해상.
앵케형.
그러니까 10년보다 짧은 애들.
그리고 예를 들어 5에서 10년 주기를 갖고 목성 궤도 영향을 받는 애들이
목성족 해상인 거고.
음.
그리고 20에서 200년 있잖아요.
네.
얘네들은 이제 보통 헨리해상.
오.
그러니까 헨리해상과다.
그게.
네.
그렇죠.
세분화를 합니다.
헨리해상 70몇 년에 한 번씩 온다고 하니까 그 사이에 껴있네.
껴있죠.
그래서 이런 애가 있고 아까도 이제 우리 침착맨님 헷갈리셨지만
해상이 보통 소행성이랑 유성이랑 헷갈립니다.
음.
네.
그래서 유성.
유성은 해성이나 소행성으로부터 떨어져 나오네요.
부스러기.
흘린 거야.
유성이나 소행성은 큽니다.
걔네가 뭔가를 흘려요.
그 흘린 부스러기가 이제 우주에 떠도는 거죠.
그러니까 그냥 뭔가 흘려서 쓰레기야.
그런데 이거를 태양계를 막 떠돌다가.
유성이 쓰레기예요?
그렇습니다.
남겨놓은 그 찌끄레기.
그건 좀 유성 입장에서는 좀 쓰레기라고 하면.
그런데 쓰레기예요 사실.
어?
그러니까 찌끄레기.
갈비지라고요?
그러니까 쓰레기를 어떻게 정의하느냐인데 그냥 찌끄레기 같은 거죠.
찌끄레기?
해성에게는 필요 없는 것인 건 거죠.
아.
남들은 쓰레기라고 보지만.
그렇죠.
유성이 입장에서 뭐 하나 써야겠는데요.
사람들한테는 그 운석이 엄청 보물인 거잖아요.
아니.
운석이랑 또 달라.
그런데 이것도 맞아요.
운석이 사실 유성이 시작되긴 하죠.
그래서 일단 제가 정리해 드릴게요.
그러니까 우리는 어떤 관점에서 말씀드리냐면 별똥별이 일단 유성의 다른 이름이에요.
별똥별을 보면서 소원을 비는 이유는 별똥별이 굉장히 찰날을 지나가고 굉장히 귀한 경험이잖아요.
그래서 그 짧은 순간에 소원을 비는 거거든요.
그런데 별똥별이.
그런데 별똥별이 하늘에서 떨어진다고 생각을 해요.
별똥별이 예를 들어 지구가 있어.
쭈우우우우우우우우.
우와아.
이렇게 생각하는데 반대인 거예요.
반대.
그니까 원래 찌끄레기가 있어요.
그런데 지구가 돌다가 그 찌끄레기 근처로 가니까 어 하고 딸려오는 거예요.
그러니까 예를 들어 모가 지구로 뿅 이게 아니라 지구가 모오오오.
이렇게 되는 거지.
지구가 쓰레기 수집하는 거네.
그렇죠.
그러니까 쓰레기를 쓰레기통에 꼬린.
이게 아니라.
쓰레기를 주우러 가는 거야 쓰레바디가
이런 느낌인 거야
지구가 가는 거야
이거를 몰라서 유성우라는 게 있어 유성우
사자자리 유성우 이런 게 있습니다 겨울에
그게 이제 빛처럼 유성이 쏟아진다
그럼 생각해보세요
쓰레기통에 막 쓰레기를 던지는 것 같잖아
그게 아니라 바닥에 쓰레기가 널려있는 구역을
지구가 지나가면서 쓰레바디로 싹 담는 거죠
흰수염고래가 플랑크톤 먹으러 가는 것처럼
그래서 유성우 빛처럼 쏟아지는 시기가 있는 거야
그래서 이런 애가 유성이란 말이죠
이쁜데 이쁘긴 이쁘다
별똥별이 지구로 떨어지는 게 아니라
찌끄레기를 지구가 먹으러 간다
그럼 느낌 좀 다르다 그렇죠?
다르죠 다르죠
그렇게 생각해보니까
누가 입에 넣어주는 게 아니라
내가 입을 벌리고 주워먹는 거다
이렇게 보면 될 것 같고
그래서 보통 게임 속에서 혹은 만화 속에서
소환사들이 소환하는 거
적 위로 떨어뜨리는 게 보통 유성이에요
그러니까 엄밀히 말하면 이것도 관점이 바뀌어요
소환수가
메테오 유성 소환 이게 아니라
지구를 찌끄레기 쪽으로 옮기는 거야 소환수가
더 대단한 거네?
지구야 먹으러 가자
더 대단한 거죠
후지토라 대단하네
지구야 먹으러 가자
그러면 지구가 궤도를 딱 틀어서
유성이 떨어지는 쪽으로 쓰레바지를 집어넣는 거지
그걸로 공격을 하는 스킬이었구나
그렇죠 그러니까 유성 소환이라고 하긴 좀 어렵고
오히려 지구를 움직이는 느낌으로
최강자잖아 그러면 세계관에
물론 이제 지구의 지상까지 도달하기 어렵습니다
왜냐면 대기권에서 굉장히 빠르게 타버려요
그래서 공격력이 사실 없어요
그래서 유성을 소환해서 마법을 부리는 거 자체가 어려운 게
대부분의 유성은 대기권에서 탈 겁니다
그래서 소환했는데 아무런 타격이 없는 경우가 제일 크겠죠
일반적으로는
근데 타고 남은 유성이 운 좋게 지상에 떨어졌어
덩어리가 있어
이때부터 얘 이름이 운석으로 바뀌는 거야
운 좋게 떨어져서?
음...
그러네 그렇게 외우면 되겠네
운 좋게 떨어졌다 보자
그럴 수도 있어 운 좋게 떨어졌다 보자
그럴 수도 있어
그래서 유성은 찌끄레기
근데 얘가 땅까지 일단 닿아서
피니시 라인을 통과했다
그러면 이때부터 얘는 운석으로 돼요
근데 걔는 사실 찌끄레기라고 하는데
지구에서 오면 되게 귀해지잖아요
맞아요 맞아요
그래서 핫했던 애 중에 청주 운석이지 청주 운석
와 소름끼쳐
얘는 진짜 귀하네요
와
그래요?
네 이게 운석도 종류가 여러 가지 있습니다
이게 1970년대 충북 청원군 미원면에서 낙하됐어요
그러니까 얘가 저 상태 그대로
땅까지 닿은 거죠
사라졌으면 그냥 유성인데
닿았기 때문에 운석이 된 거고요
당시 10대였던 이영포 씨 가족이
심야에 굉음이 들려서 나갔습니다
딱 나갔더니 소가 놀라서 넘어져 있더라
소가?
소가
소가 넘어갔어
소가 넘어갔고
외양간 뒤쪽 밭이 파여서 웅덩이가 생겼는데
그 웅덩이 안에 탄화된 재와 함께
저 녀석이 박혀 있었다라고 주장을 했습니다
그래서 경상대 지구환경공학원에서
과학과에서 이걸 감정을 해 봤더니
2kg이 넘는 철 운석이라는 것이 확인이 됐습니다
그래서 발견 당시 그 당시에
2천만 원 이상의 가치가 있는 돌이었습니다
왜 가치가 있느냐
얘가 철 운석이에요 철 운석
또 유명한 애가 진주 운석이 있어요
와 뭐야 어떻게 그렇게 됐지?
진주에서 4개 운석이 발견됐는데요
이 4개가 전부 콘드라이트 재질인 석질 운석입니다
그래서
발견되는 대부분의 운석은 이런 콘드라이트 재질
무려 86%가 넘는 비율이 콘드라이트입니다
그게 뭐 좋은 거예요?
그냥 돌 석질 운석입니다
그래서 철 운석이 석질 운석 대비해서는 굉장히 드물어요
그러니까 가치가 훨씬 높죠
그럼 저거를 이제 해서 어디다 쓰는 거예요?
그냥 구경하는 거예요?
아 분석할 게 되게 많죠
우주에서 왔기 때문에 얘가 어디서 왔을까
그다음에 오늘 오면서 어떤 걸 겪었을까
이런 것들을 통해서 어쩌면 우리가
절대 알아낼 수 없는 정보를 갖고 온
일종의 멀리서 온 뿌락지 같은 애들이야
멀리서 온 뿌락지들
그럼 얘가 얘의 궤도에
거쳐왔던 거에 정보를 담고 있으니까
간접적으로 알 수 있구나
그 공간에 뭐가 있는지
그리고 얘네가 어디서 왔을까를 통해서
아 얘네들이 도대체 어디서 만들어졌고
나아가서 이 태양계 형성에 대한
굉장한 많은 힌트를 줍니다
무협지 같은 데는 아까 그 철 있잖아요
그걸로 무기 만들어요
오오오오
엄청 세요
그렇게 세겠네요
우주에서 온 애들은 지구랑은
어? 달라요?
좀 다르죠
구성이 다르죠 구성이
그러니까 그런 생각을 해볼 수 있겠죠
왜냐면은 지구에서는 만들어질 수 없는 형태구나
예를 들어서 중성자별 같은 애들
이거 우리 어벤져스 보시면 토르가
중성자별에 가서 본인의 무기를 만들어요
아시죠 그 묠니를 부서지고 나서
스톤브레이커 만들어 오잖아요
중성자별에서 만드는 게 되게 이성적인 판단이에요
왜냐면은 결국은 존재하는
물질은 얘를 얼마나 단단하게 모아서
두드려 팼느냐
중성자별은 중력이 엄청 강하단 말이에요
거기서는 미친듯이 얘네들이 뭉치겠죠
그러니까 일종의 어마어마한 무기를 만드는 공장으로
중성자별을 선택하면 좋고
이렇게 만들어진 애들이 우연히 지구로 들어와
지구에서는 그만한 중력을 재현하기 어렵기 때문에
어마어마한 강도를 가질 수도 있죠
이거는 상상이지만
그래서 그게 강하다는 설정이구나
그쵸
뭉쳐놓고 왔으니까
왜냐면 중성자별에서만 그걸 뭉칠 수 있는 설정인 거죠
중력 자체가 모으는 힘이잖아요
그럼 그 중앙에 딱 모아버리면 이거는 절대 깰 수 없거든요
너무 튼튼하게 모이니까
어쨌든 그래서 이제 요게 운석이고
소행성은 뭐냐
얘는 목성 궤도 안쪽에서 태양 주위를 공전하는
수많은 천체들이 소행성입니다
어린왕자 집안이에요
그니까 작은 행성
어린왕자도 오류가 되게 많죠
어린왕자가 살고 있는 그 행성이
어린왕자 한번 찾아볼 수 있어요?
어린왕자네 집 아니야 저거?
그 행성에 앉아있는 뒷모습이요?
네
오류가 많아요
아 죄송해요
아까 본거는 안보셨는데
창을 왜 안 닫았어요
창을 닫아놔야죠
어린왕자를 검색했어요
네 저 첫 장면
책이 딱 있죠
요기 보시면 어린왕자가 사는 행성이 오류가 좀 많은 게
너무 구형이에요
이게 구형을 이루려면
동그랄 수 없다
네 꽤 커져야 됩니다
꽤 무거워져야 되고
근데 소행성의 특징이 구형이 어려워요
왜냐면 중력이 약해서 얘네들을 예쁘게 못 뭉쳐
우리가 예쁘게 뭉치려면
힘으로 팍 해서 예쁘게 해야 되는데
중력이 약하니까 덕지덕지 붙다가 마는 거예요
그래서 소행성은 저렇게 깔끔한 구형이 될 수 없다
생택질베리가 사실은 자문을 안 받았던 거죠
근데 이게 구형이 될 수도 있잖아요
될 수 있는데 사실 과학도 되지 않죠
그렇게 따지면 그거 외에도 대기 조건이 어떤지는 모르겠지만
목도리도 날아가고 있죠
이거요
그리고 장미꽃과 여우가 있어요
맞아
생태계가 순환하지 못합니다
장미꽃이 자라도 여우는 먹을 게 장미꽃밖에 없는데
여우는 사실은 채식을 하지 않아요
초식동물이 아니야
그럼 사실 생태계 자체가
사실이 없다
그러니까 쟤네들은 그냥 개체가 죽으면 끝나는 행성이에요
근데 저 여우는 지구여우 아니야?
지구여우고 이거는 덮어놨는데
어쨌든 저기 살 거 아니에요
저기에 사는
그러니까 저기는 사실 생태계 자체가 없는 거예요
그러니까 생존이 불가능한 혹독한 환경에
어린왕자가 저기에 있는 거 자체가 말이 안 되는 상황이죠
그래요?
행성의 모양도 그렇고 크기도 그렇고
사실 저렇게 작은 소행성이면 저렇게 서 있는 것도 쉽지 않을 것이다
잘못 툭 치면 우주로 날아갑니다
나는 근데 이거 여우가 여기로 와요?
지구에 사는 여우 아니야?
난 얘가 지구로 간 건 줄 알았는데
진짜 딴소리 많이 하신다
일단 다시 돌아가겠습니다
소행성으로 돌아갈게요 소행성으로
자 소행성으로 갑니다
그래서 소행성으로 돌아가 보겠습니다
암튼 소행성 같은 경우는요?
소행성으로 돌아가겠습니다
이 경우가 목성 궤도 안쪽에서 태양 주위를 공존하는
아주 많은 천체들이고요
그래서 이 소행성이 등장한 작품
바로 TVNL 1일시스콘 감자별이라는 작품이 있습니다
2013 QR3
아세요?
아니 들어는 봤어요 근데 안 봤어요
이 작품이 사실은 여기 보이세요? 장기하 형님?
네 장기하 형님 데뷔작입니다
아 그래요?
이 작품을 통해 데뷔한 사람이 두 분이 계세요
장기하 앤 궤도
궤도 님도 나왔어요
제 데뷔작이 있고
그렇구나
이때 2013년 이후로 지금 13년째 다음 작품을 좀 고르고 있는데
아 신중해야 돼요
교수님이 나왔다고요?
네
지금 셀렉 중이에요
왜 나오셨어요?
왜냐면 또
어쩌다가?
네 또 이 과학자 역할로
연기 잘해서 나왔죠
그렇구나
예 나온 이유가 뭐겠어요? 연기를 잘하니까 나왔죠
제가 시트콤 출신이에요
어쨌든 여기서 나오는 저 앞에 있는 감자별
2013 QR3라는 애가 소행성이라는 설정입니다
그래서 보시면은 감자 형태처럼 구형이 아니죠?
소행성이 아니라 소행성이라는 설정입니다
소행성에 대한 고증을 잘하신 거죠 우리 감독님께서
꾸룩꾸룩하게
네 그래서 우리 김병욱 감독님이 굉장하신 분이고
이때 소행성이 지구를 멸망시킬 뻔하는 상황을
이렇게 만든 게 이 작품입니다
근데 이제 다행히 감자별이랑 2013 QR3라는 소행성이
지구 궤도에 편입이 돼서 지구 주위를 돌아요
그래서 달이 두 개가 되는 설정이에요
오
달과 감자별의 위치나 거리나 이런 거에 따라서
등장인물들의 어떤
여러 가지 상황을 은유를 했습니다
굉장히 현실적인 작품이고
제가 여기서 감자별의 궤도를 제가 계산을 했는데
아주 이십률이 큰 궤도를 디자인해서
감독님 요청이 이거였어요
정확하게 몇 날 며칠 몇 시에 감자별이 어디서 어떻게 보이는지를 알아야 된다
실제 천체처럼
굉장히 이십률이 큰 기울어진 궤도를 이렇게 만들어서
몇 월 며칠 몇 시에 어느 하늘에 떠 있는지
이거를 다 설정해드렸죠
사실 보는 사람들은
모를 때인데도
상관없는데도
아무 상관없는데 시청자 게시판에
그러면 몇 날 며칠 몇 시에 어느 쪽 하늘에 감자별이 있는 겁니까
라는 질문이 왔을 때 답을 할 수 있어야 된다
그래서 제가 궤도를 디자인해서 그거에 대한 위치를 다 만들어드렸어요
아 근데 가끔 드라마나 영화에
로맨스 장면이나 뭐에 이렇게
밤하늘 은하수나 별이 나올 때 있잖아요
별자리가 하나도 안 맞아서 좀 스트레스 받긴 하거든요
맞아 맞아 맞아
그래요?
맞아 이거 아는 분들은 그래요
아니 너무 그냥 반짝반짝한 것만 해놨는데
전혀 안 맞는데
그냥 이거
가져와서
계절에 안 맞는 그 별자리가 있어요?
네 이런 경우가 많고
실제로 제일 유명한 이야기가 타이타닉
타이타닉에서 밤하늘이 쫙 나오는데
그 시기랑 안 맞아요
근데 제임스 카멜룬 감독님이 진짜 집요한 분이에요
그 이야기를 듣고 나중에 DVD판인가 감독판이 나왔을 때
밤하늘을 교체합니다
와
그래서 그 순간에 거기서 보이는 밤하늘을 교체를 했고요
그렇구나
그게 보이는 사람은 딱 보이나 봐요
예를 들어서 이제
남방구에서 벌어지는 어떤 일이 있는데 북극성이 보인다던가
그럼 확 튀죠
남방구 북방구는 별자리가 다르고
남식자성 같은 애들은 사실 이제 북방구에서는 안 보이니까
그런 것들이 딱 보일 수 있어요
남극성도 있어요?
8분의 자리 맞아
8분의 자리에요
1분의 자리
8분의 자리에 있는 별일 거예요
왜냐면 제가 남방구를 가봤거든요
유나님 왜 이렇게 잘하시냐고 하는데요
남방구를 그때 한번 여행으로 갔다가
아 극축정렬 할 때 북극성이 없으니까
딴 걸로 하는구나
저도 남식자일 줄 알았어요
근데 남식자가 아니었던 걸 그때 처음 알아서
와
어쨌든 그래서 이 소행성은 꽤 길었던 공룡의 장기 집권을 종결시켰던
대멸종의 가장 유력한 후보이기도 하고
현재 이제 나사 미항공우주국에서는 가장 위험한
요주의 천체로 여러 가지 위험성을 보고 있는 친구이기도 합니다
혜성 같은 경우가 지금 저 길게 도는 애
보이시죠?
요런 애들이 혜성인데요
띠인 거
네
얘의 궤도를 보시면은 태양 곁을 돌아요
돌지만 굉장히 길쭉한 타운 궤도입니다
어 저거다 아틀라스
얼마 전에 온 거잖아요
A3
맞아요
어 저거 보러 간 거예요 춘천에
2023년? 2023년?
네
어 맞아요 맞아요
아 저 네임드에요?
네 네 네 네임드에요 얼마 전에 왔었던
제일 최근에 있었던
한국에서도 보였어요
이거를 직접 가서 보신 거군요
네네
이거 그니까 보고 온 사람은 이 내공이 달라요
아
내가 한 날 말로 떴어요?
그거 들어봐야 난 못 봤거든
아 못 봤어요? 아틀라스?
못 봤어
아긴 너무 바빴으니까
그거 막 사진 찍어서
그럼 언제 볼 수 있어요?
반칙에 별로 좀
이제는 못 보죠
궤도가 이제 다시 보기 좀 어렵겠는데?
네 그때 얼마라 했지?
60년이라 했나?
뭐 얼마라 했는데?
유나님이 사실 과학 커뮤니케이터이기 때문에
과학 커뮤니케이터 맞네요
저는 과학 애호가로서
윤밋 궤도 굉장히 저는 좋습니다
둘 다 커뮤니케이터 같아요 과학 커뮤니케이터
되게 뭔가 석양이 이렇게 지면서
점점점점 뚜렷해지는 거예요
이 현장 경험담
그 느낌이 어때요 느낌이
너무 신기한 거예요
그냥 별도 아니고
그냥 먼지처럼 이렇게 보이긴 하거든요
근데 개가 계속 떠 있죠
응 꼬리가 있고 계속 떠 있는데
점점 어두워지면서 더 선명해지는 그게
와 추천에서도 볼 수 있구나 이러면서 봤어요
그 짧은 시기에 좀 정 들었나요?
어 정 들었죠
정 들었어요?
유성은 떨어져요
근데 혜성은 떠 있는 게 이게 뜨고 지는 겁니다
며칠 동안 보여요
네 지구가 도니까
진짜 거의 몇 개월간 간직되는 애도 있어요
아 그래요?
심지어 정말 몇 개월간
보통 우리가 빨리 사라진다면
여러 가지 이름을 붙이는데 여러 옵션이 있을 거예요
근데 뭐 1997년 대해성
꽤 길게 보인다는 거죠
그런 것들이 다 어떻게 보면
네 그래서 어떻게 보면
굉장히 길쭉한 타원 궤도를 그리고요
주성분이 얼음과 먼지라서
태양 근처를 지나가면 녹아요
그러니까 궤도 위에 표면에 얼음이 녹으면서
갇혀 있던 먼지를 흩뿌리면서 지나갑니다
녹으면서 먼지들을 남기고 가는 거죠
그러면요
쟤네는 이제 지나갈 때마다 계속 녹아서 소모가 되잖아요
지나가면서 먼지 같은 거 다시 붙이면서 충전을 해요?
아니면 계속 하다가 사라져요?
네 뭉쳐지는 거는 사실 쉽지는 않을 것 같아요
한 번 뭉쳐놓고 계속 쓰면서 가는 건가?
네네네
왜냐면 이게 다시 충전되기엔 속도가 굉장히 빨라가지고
어 그러면 타다가 결국에 없어지는 거예요?
그럴 수도 있죠
다이어트를 하다 소멸되는?
그렇죠
그래서 이렇게 남기는 태양 근처로 갈 때 먼지를 남기는
이런 게 이제 먼지 꼬리
이게 먼지 꼬리
깔끔하게 먼지를 쫙 뿌리면서 이동을 한 거죠
잘 보이죠 먼지가?
이런 건 이제 먼지 꼬리라고요
사실 꼬리가 하나 더 있습니다
태양에서 나온 입자들
즉 태양풍이 해성이랑 부딪혀요
그럼 이때 꼬리가 하나 더 만들어지는데
태양풍 때문에 어떤 고에너지 이온들이 이렇게
태양풍이 흘러가는 방향으로 만들어져요
그러니까 뭔가를 태양풍이 때리니까
두드려 맞아서 있는데 이온들이 이렇게 나가는 거죠
그래서 이렇게 발생한 고에너지 이온들이 만드는
태양이 있는 방향과 태양풍이 나오니까
정반대로 뻗어나가는 꼬리가 있습니다
그게 이제 이온 꼬리
아 그렇구나
그렇죠
그럼 저 흰색은 태양풍이에요?
흰색은 먼지 꼬리
아 저게 먼지 꼬리고 저게 태양풍이에요?
그렇죠 이걸 보면은 그러면은
이 해성이 어떤 경로로 이동했는지를 알 수 있겠죠?
먼지 꼬리를 보면
그리고 어떻게 보면은 태양의 위치가 어딘지도 알 수 있겠죠
왜냐하면 태양의 반대 방향으로
태양풍 때문에 이온 꼬리를 만드니까
그래서 육안으로 보면은 사실 먼지 꼬리가 굉장히 잘 보입니다
이온 꼬리보다는
그래서 이걸 소재로 작품을 만드신 분이 계십니다
특유의 화려한 효과로 빛의 마술사라 불리는 바로
신카이 마코토
신카이 마코토 감독님이
2016년 해성 충돌로 사라지는 마을을 소재로 한
장편 애니메이션 영화
너의 이름은을 선보입니다
음 알아요 이거
네 이거 줄거리 아시죠?
소녀가 작은 마을 도시에 소년이 있다
근데 이제 어떤 계기로 둘의 몸이 바뀌고
지속적인 교체가 반복되는 이 와중에
1200년 주기로 찾아오는 티아마트 해성이라는 것이
이제 마을로 떨어지게 됩니다
이렇게 만들어지는 건데
이거 보셨어요?
저 여러 번 봤어요 저는 진짜
타키끈
너무 감동
김인호 남아해와
남아해와
보세요
먼지꼬리와
가잘떠무소
오 너무 슬퍼
이거 그때 나레이션인데
그날 별이 무수히 쏟아지던 날
그것은 마치 꿈속 풍경처럼
그저 한없이 아름다운 광경이었다
이거 제가 팁인데
해성이던 유성우던
천체 관측할 때
너의 이름은 OST를 들으면서 보잖아요
네
따라란
좋아 너무 좋아
그러니까 이거 진짜
한번 해보세요
사자자리 유성우 떨어질 때
그걸 딱 들으면서 같이
데이트하면서
좋은데?
네 좋죠
어쨌든 이 티아마트 해성은
실제 천체 아닙니다 가상의 천체고요
근데 파괴력이 어마어마한 걸로 극중에 나오죠
그래서 파괴력을 보면은
요거를 이제 대충 알아볼 수 있어요
물론 이게 정확하게 어떤 해성이냐
요거를 이제 설명하기는 어렵지만
예시로
요게 1908년
러시아 퉁구스카 지역의 30m 크기의 소에인가요?
소행성이 공중에서 폭발한 겁니다
추락이 아니고 폭발했어
근데 저렇게 날아왔어요?
수천 킬로미터 지역이 초토화가 됐고요
이때 쓰러진 나무의 개수가 8천만 그룹입니다
이거 뭐 충격파 때문에요?
공중폭발인데 충격파로 밖에 나가니까
나무들이 다 누워있는 거예요
저 거목들이
와 소름끼치네
그래서 이 정도의 파워가 있다
30m짜리 소행성이
이건 뭐예요?
중간중간 이렇게 있는 거?
나무들이
쟤네들이 왜 안 쓰러졌어요?
오히려 얘네들은 좀 잘 버틴 거죠
쓰러지기 전에 뒤에 있던 애들
넘어가고 얘가 이제 좀 버티낼 수 있고
노래 하나 나오겠는데요?
그러게요
큰 나무들이 지켜줬어 작은 나무들을
오히려 좀 가늘고 얇아서 버텼을 수 있을 것 같고
약간 그런 거 있잖아요
갈대는 꺾이지 않잖아
그런 느낌
거목은 꺾여도
15층 아파트 정도 되는 우주물체가 떨어지면
도시가 하나가 사라집니다
서울시만한 도시요?
서울시 정도 되는 도시가 사라질 수 있어요
오 너무
그 위치가 그러면
사람 많이 모여있는데
떨어지면은
치명적이죠
산 이런 데가 아니고
그쵸
퉁구스카도 나무가 있는데 떨어져서 다행인 거예요
그러니까 이제 나사도 그렇고
우리나라의 한국천문연구원도
이런 것들을 대비를 하기 위해서
다 고려를 하고 있는 거고
만약에 종합운동장만한 천체가 떨어졌다
막 4만 5천석 되잖아요
그게 떨어지면 국가가 사라지는 경우도 있을 거라고 보고 있죠
그리고 수 킬로미터가 넘는 천체다
이렇게 큰 애가 떨어지면 문명이 아예 리셋된다
그래서 이제 위험하다고 보는 건데
아직 인류가
지구에 자리 잡은 이후에는
그 정도의 위기는 아직까지 없었다
네 그래서 괜찮다는 거고요
할 수도 있잖아요 떨어질 수도 있어요
맞아요 저놈입니다
글리제 710
제가 지금 오고 있는데
얘 때문에 지구가 거의 폭격당할 수도 있다
제 무거운 중력에 이끌려서
수많은 해성이나 소행성들이 오니까
그래서 이제 글리제 710이라는 애에 대한 이야기인데
요게 언제쯤 벌어지느냐가 핵심이죠
128만 년 후로 보고 있어요
128만 년?
네 그래서 아직 뭐 사실 고민할 정도는 아니야
저 그때 노래 나왔네요
글리제의 우울
또 나왔네
어쨌든 그리고 이게 오늘 주제가 이제 파편의 과학입니다
이거 관련해서 정말 역사상 미친 프로젝트
제가 잠깐 잠깐씩 언급한 적이 있거든요
혹시 기억하실지 모르겠는데
해성에 착륙한 로제타 프로젝트 혹시 기억나십니까?
예 이름만 기억나요
미친 프로젝트요
이거 진짜 역사상 가장 미친 프로젝트라고 불리는 건데
저기 보이는 애가 이제 로제타라는 탐사선이고요
1986년 이미 유럽 주국 2사가
헨리해성 근처로 지오토라는 탐사선을 보냈습니다
근처라고 하면 600km 정도 돼요
그러니까 이미 이 산은 관심이 굉장히 많았다 이런 탐사에
그래서 지오토란 이름 자체가
르네상스 시대 이탈리아 미술가 조토 디 본돈의 이름에서 따왔습니다
네 지오토란 이름인데
600km 거리면은 사실 진짜 코앞이에요 코앞
그래요? 600km?
잘못하면 부딪힐 정도로 가까운 상황이라고 보는 거죠
서울에서 부산 거리?
너무 가까운 거 너무 가까운 거
하긴 움직이니까
얘네 관점에서는
그래서 정말 가까이서 봤더니 아 밝혀졌어
더러운 눈덩이였다
얼음과 먼지가 뭉쳐진
그렇게 가설을 세우고 눈으로 본 건 처음인데
가까이서 봤더니 정말 더러운 눈덩이였다
이걸 확인한 거죠
이렇게 말했어요? 더러운 눈덩이라고?
아 제가 말했어요 그렇게
그런 식으로 말했는데
왜냐면 전 깨끗해서
눈덩이 더러워도 좀 깨끗하잖아요 밝게 보면
네 그래서 어쨌든
보통 얼음과 먼지인데
구체적인 데이터가 없었어요
도대체 어떻게 구성돼 있냐
그리고 재밌는 게
혜성 대부분이 태양계 초창기에 만들어진 이후에
냉동고 수준으로 그대로 보존돼 있던 애들이야
그니까 보관이 너무너무 잘 된 천체예요
얼마나 궁금해
예를 들어 우리가 뭘 발견했는데
한 번도 누구도 간 적 없는 곳이야
그럼 정말 정말 신기한 게 많잖아
그래서 이제 혜성을 탐사해야겠다
그러니까 그냥 진짜 고인물 중에서
혜성의 고인물입니다
그래서 이렇게 존버한 천체에
실제로 가서 보존된 정보를 가져올 수 있다면
얼마나 많은 것들이 바뀔까
그래서 했어요
그래서 태양계가 어떻게 생겼고
지구가 어떻게 형성됐고
이런 것들에 대한 결정적인 단서를 알 수 있을 것이다
해서 나사랑 협력을 하려고 합니다
이사가 아이디어를 내요
혜성에 착륙을 했다가 샘플을 채취해서 돌아오자
와 가능?
근데 저 혜성의 속도가
우리가 상상할 수 있는 속도가 아니에요
빨라요
총알은 상대가 안 됩니다
약간 뛰는 칠타 위에 올라타는 것 같은 느낌인 거 아니에요?
그러니까 총알 위에 올라탈 수 있어요?
아는 거 다요?
총알 위에 올라타는 것보다 훨씬 어려운 거예요
총알보다 훨씬 빨라요
그럼 계산을 해야겠네요
계산을 해야죠
비슷한 속도를 만들어서 상대 속도를 맞춰가지고 올라타야 돼
근데 나사가 일단 그래서 도와주기로 약속을 하고
혜성 근방에서 정보를 수집하는 건 나사가 한다
근데 이제 1992년 이야기가 잘 되다가
계산 문제로 나사가 발을 뺍니다
그래서 이사가 뭐야 우리 혼자 이걸 어떻게 해
이거 미친 프로젝트인데
그래가지고 고민을 하다가 방향을 전환한 게 바로 이 로제타 프로젝트입니다
나사가 발을 뺐으니까
좋아 그냥 나사가 하는 일도 우리가 하자
그래서 주변을 관측하는 거는 원래 나사가 하기로 했는데
발을 빼니까 우리가 주변도 돌고 착륙도 해보자
그래서 밀고 나갑니다
그래서 일단 착륙해서 샘플을 채취해서 돌아오는 거를 목표로 했었는데
이건 너무 어려우니까
대신 혜성에 근접해서 혜성 주위를 도는 인공위성을 만들자
그게 이제 로제타라는 저 탐사선이 그 역할을 한다는 거죠
그 다음에 착륙선을 내려서 걔는 혜성에 붙어서 한번 직접 관측을 하자
결국 이 로제타 프로젝트도 또 나사가 도와주긴 해요 나중에
나중에는?
나중에는 다시 돌아오는데
어쨌든 이 로제타가 이제 로제타 스톤 아시죠?
이지트 성형문자 해독에 결정적인 기여를 했던 로제타 스톤에서 유래됐습니다
그러니까 이게 세 가지의 어떤 다른 형태의 문자잖아요
세 가지가 돌 하나에 같이 적혀있는데 이 세 가지가 같은 내용이에요
그러니까 로제타 스톤 때문에 우리가 모르는 고대 문자를 이해하는데 큰 도움을 줬어요
우리가 문자를 몰라도 예를 들어 한국어밖에 몰라
근데 일본어, 영어, 프랑스어 이렇게 적혀있으면
이 셋의 관계를 통해서 여러 가지 유추할 수 있잖아요
그래서 그걸 통해서 굉장히 많은 실마리를 제공했던 스톤인데
이것 때문에 우리가 로제타 스톤에서 이름을 따서 로제타 프로젝트 해보자
그리고 착륙선의 이름이 필레입니다 필레
필레
그래서 로제타 필레라고 하거든요
필레는 안심 아니에요?
아 그런가요?
안심이 된다는 거지
이게 문자 해독에 중요한 역할을 했던 오베리스크가 있던 나일강의 섬의 이름에서 유래됐어요 필레는
그래서 착륙 예정 지역 이름이 아질키아
그래서 로제타가 가서 필레를 내리고 아질키아에 한번 필레를 내려보자
이렇게 되는 거죠 이름들이 다 의미가 있고
그래서 2004년 3월 유럽우주공항
한국에 로제타호가 발사가 됩니다
중량 2,900kg의 대형 탐사선이고요
연료만 1,700kg입니다
그러니까 전체 무게 절반이 넘어요
이 말이 뭐냐? 엄청나게 먼 길을 가야 된다 빠르게
그리고 착륙선 필레가 100kg
그리고 착륙할 지역의 이름이 저기 아래쪽에 나와 있죠
슈류모프 게라시멘코 해성 저해성에 착륙하겠다
얘가 태양에서 가장 멀리서는
태양에서 가장 멀리서는
태양에서 가장 멀리 떨어지면 800,000,000km가 넘고요
가장 가까워도 200,000,000km
사실상 어마어마하게 먼 거리에 있는 해성인데
속도가 엄청 빠른데 연료가 저속도를 따라잡으려면 너무 많이 들어요
그래서 현재 예산이나 우리의 기술로는 저 정도로 속도를 따라잡기 어렵다
총알보다 빨라야 되니까 훨씬
그래가지고 뭘 하느냐 스윙바이
다른 행성과 소행성의 중력, 소행성 중력까지 이용을 합니다
중력으로 가속을 하는 거예요
지구 중력 이용한다, 지구 주위를 돌면서 지구가 돌리다가 슝
그래서 지구가 에너지를 잃고 그 에너지만큼 가속돼요
근데 지구가 잃는 에너지가 굉장히 적기 때문에 지구는 거의 타격이 없죠
지금 보시면은 2005년에 일단 지구를 첫 번째 스윙바이 합니다
Flyby라고 써있죠
그다음에 두 번째로 2007년에 다시 지구를 돌아요
그다음에 2008년에 소행성을 스윙바이 합니다
2009년 다시 지구를 돌고 2011년에 다시 소행성 루테티아를 스윙바이 하고
2011년에 잠깐 동면에 들어갔다가
2014년 3년 후에 때가 돼서 다시 일어나서 해성 주위를 근접한다
그래서 2014년 8월까지 11년 동안 무려 여러 개 행성과 소행성의 중력의 도움을 받아서
65억 킬로미터를 비행을 합니다
이걸 어떻게 다 계산을 한대요?
이거를 하는 게 제 전공인 궤도 과학자들이 하는 거예요
우와 멋지다
제가 한 건 아닙니다
전공을 하는 훌륭한 과학자분들이 하신 거고
근데 만약에 이거 다 계산해가지고 보냈는데
아 덧셈 빼먹었다 이러면
그럴 수도 있어요
그럼 어떡해
그런 일이 없어야죠
그래서 정말 복잡한 시뮬레이션을 하고
결국은 무려 10년이 지난 끝에 목적지인 해성을 따라잡아요
네 그래서 찍었어
우와 이거 진짜 찍은 거예요?
찍었어요
로제타가 해성에 근접해서 촬영을 했습니다
이렇게 찍은 거 정말 충격적이죠
진짜 충격적이다
근데 이거 진짜 충격적이잖아요
그러니까
우리가 생각하던 해성이랑은
느낌이 완전 달라요
너무 다르고
지금까지 배운 내용들을 다 뒤집어야 될 정도로
전면 수정이 필요할 정도로 특이한 모양이에요
이상하게 생겼어
야생의 해성이네 진짜
그쵸 그쵸
그래서 2014년 9월에 해성에서 뿜어져 나오는
가스의 제트도 관측을 합니다
해성이 꼬리를 만들잖아요
근데 그 꼬리를 만드는 과정은 알았지만
실제로 가까이서 본 건 처음이죠
선명하게 이 관측을 했고요
꼬리를 만드는 과정도
우와
뭐가 좀 막 이렇게 튀어나오죠?
네
그리고 신중하게 착륙 후보지를 골라야 되는데
아까 말씀하신 아질키아
여기가 착륙 예정 지역이었습니다
그리고 2014년 11월 12일
10년에 걸친 역사적인 미션입니다
이거 정말 어마어마하게 어려운 이유가
속도도 그렇지만
중력이 지구의 10만 분의 1이에요
그럼 거의 없는 거 아니에요?
거의 없죠
그러니까 내린다라는 개념이
없는 건가요?
어 쉽지 않아요
매달려 있어야겠다
네 매달려야 돼
그래서 어떻게 합니까?
필레는 다리 세 개로 여기 버텨야 되니까
다리 세 개로 내리면서
작살도 두 개를 준비합니다
꽂아서 버티려고
그러니까 빈 벽 이렇게
그렇죠
미친 듯한 속도로 달리는
해성의 벽에
다리 세 개로 달라붙어서
작살 두 개를 꽂아야 되는 상황이었어요
그래서 로제타와 분리를 했고요
이 필레가 무려 7시간 동안
천천히 떨어집니다
이거 10년 동안
정말 수천 명의 과학자들이 여기에 참여를 해가지고
진짜 이 날만을 기억하고 있어요
이 날만을 기다린 거야
그래서 보세요 되게 재밌어요
분리되는 순간에 필레가 내려가고 있잖아요
그 다리 세 개 달린 놈이
얘가 로제타를 찍은 겁니다
보이시죠?
이거는 필레 관점
로제타도 찍었겠죠
겁나 귀여워
내려가는 필레를 로제타가 찍습니다
100kg
100kg 짜리
저 조그만 게 뭘 할 거야
제가 이 인류의 염원을 담아서 내려가는 거예요
7시간 동안
해성 표면도 촬영했고 자기장도 관측하고
플라즈마 측정하고 먼지도 관측하고
착륙 후에 해성 표면에 구멍을 뚫어가지고
암석과 토양 시료도 채취하고
해성 내부를 레이더로 탐사하는 계획까지
진짜 정말 꽉꽉 채워서 세웠어
근데 엄청난 속도로 날아가는 해성
따라잡는 거 어려워요
거기다 뭔가를 내린다?
잘 됐을까요?
근데 했어
정신 나가는 아이디어 진짜
사실은 확률이 너무 낮았어요
잘 됐을까요?
됐죠
근데 했어!
기차를 원래 탈 수 있어요?
못해요 전
탐 크루즈 형님도 진짜 고생을 많이 하잖아요
근데 날아가는 총알 위에 다른 총알을 올려놓는 겁니다
이거 아쉽게도
탐사 로봇 필레가 착륙 과정에서
두 번이나 튕겨나갑니다
그러니까 잘 내려야 되는데
근데 왜 꺼드럭대셨어요?
띵~~
중력이 약하니까 오래 걸려요 또
다시 내려가려면
띵~~
이러면 어떻게 돼?
원하던 대로 못 내렸어요
얘는 어쨌든 에너지원이 태양 전지이기 때문에
빛을 받아야 가동된단 말이야
그러면 무한대기네
네 그래서 그늘에 빠집니다
저기 보세요
띵~~
보이시죠?
퍼스트 세컨 파이널
목표로 하던 곳을 굉장히 벗어나서
태양 전지가 기능을 할 수 없는 그늘에서
장롱 밑으로 들어갔구나
태양 빛을 못 받는다?
배터리는 완전히 방전됩니다
그렇게
쓸쓸히 잠들었어요
그래서 이때 언론에서도 난리가 나고
과학자들, 대중들이
필레 일어나
한 번만 일어나
왜냐면 얘가 뭐라도 해야 될 거냐
전원이 나갔어
그게 계속 고생을 10년을 했는데
그래서 이제 모두가 염원을 하는데도
방법이 없어요?
방법이 없죠
그런데 기적이 일어납니다
해성이
틀어요?
태양에 접근을 하기 시작해요
그래서 7개월 만에
충전이 됐구나
힐끔힐끔 태양 빛을 받았어
필레가
그래서 7개월 만에 눈을 뜹니다
와 대박
야금야금 에너지를 모은 거야
얘가 그동안 모았던 귀중한 사진과 정보를
보내줘
보냈습니다
그래서 받은 거구나
네 그래서 받은 거예요
그래서 많은 것들을 받았는데
이게 사실 불가능한 임무였어요
그리고 이제 끝났다
10년간의 여정은 끝났다 했는데
정말 7개월 만에 잠시 눈을 딱 떠서
그 목적을 필레는 해냈습니다
그리고 인류가 성공을 한 거죠
그러면 이 필레가 그럼 어디 쳐박혔느냐
로제타가 찾아냈어요
진짜 못 찾아
근데
여기 있었어
와 이게 진짜 불쌍하게 떨어진 거야 저렇게
근데 저 와중에도
지가 할 일을 한 거야
오 기특해
손 들고 벌 서고 있는 거야
오 그러네
다리 보이죠 다리
다리를 쳐들고 있는 거죠
몇 달 뒤에 태양에서 멀어지니까
이제 필레는 영원히 동면합니다
그리고 이제 로제타조차도
해성주의를 돌다가
이제 에너지가 더 이상 안 들어오니까
로제타도 에너지가 점점 부족해진 상황이 돼요
그래서 결국은 이 필레도 저렇게
장렬하게 잠깐 깨서 지휘를 하고 죽었고
2016년 9월 30일
로제타가 마지막에 이제 더 이상 운행이 불가능하다라는 판단 하에
모든 과학자가 동의를 하고
해성에 추락을 시킵니다 강제로
그래서 이때 영상을 보면 되게 되게 장엄해요
그리고 마지막에 딱 추락한 걸 확인하고
과학자들이 약간 우는 분도 계시고
포옹하면서 서로 이제 좀 더 다독이고
그럼 얘랑 만나요?
아 근데 저기다 추락하진 않으니까
근데 이게 충돌 직전까지 해성을 촬영하면서
점점점점 가까워지는 그 영상도 되게 감동적이거든요
근데 어쨌든 마지막까지 장렬하게 자신을 불태우면서
마지막 이 사진을
이게 이렇게 정말 코앞까지 가서 촬영을 하고 죽었어요
이게 멀리서부터 쫙 가는 영상이 있습니다
여러분들 관심 있어 찾아보세요
쫙 들어가는데 기가 막힙니다
굳이 왜 이렇게 말도 안 되는 무모한 도전을 했을까
긴 시간과 인력을 들였을까?
해성이 지구를 위협하는 건 사실이지만
해성이 어쩌면 다른 관점에서
지구 생명체 근원이 어디서 왔는지
이 비밀을 풀어줄 수 있는 굉장히 결정적인 열쇠입니다
그래서 해성을 살아있는 태양계 화석이라고도 불러요
그래서 우리가 분석을 해 봅니다
해성의 물을 분석해 보니까
지구의 물과 해성의 물이 차이가 있어요
무거운 수소가 결합한 중수소물이
지구보다 3, 4배가 많습니다
이 말은 뭐냐?
그러면 어? 물이라는 게 결국은 소행성으로부터 왔구나
물의 근원에 대한 가설의 힘을 실을 수 있는 거죠
다른 행성에는 없고 지구에는 있는 이유가?
네, 물이 어디서 왔을까?
그럼 물이 지구에서 만들어진 게 아니라 어디서부터 유입됐는데
그걸 한 애들이 소행성인가 보다
그럼 두레박으로 계속 길러서 지금까지 많아진 거예요?
그럴 수 있는 거죠
계속 퍼서?
근데 걔네들이 녹으면서 나간 애들도 있지만
못 나가고 지구에 갇혀서 지금의 액체 상태의 물이 될 수 있다는 거죠
오, 그래요
너무 우연인데?
그렇죠, 우연이죠
엄청나게 적은 확률을?
굉장히 낮은 확률에서 생명체가 탄생할 수도 있는 거고
거기서 우리가 됐다니
그렇죠
말도 안 돼
그래서 해성의 기원 얘기를 살짝 해보자면
태양이 막 태어났을 때는 주변에 가스나 얼음, 먼지가 많았어요
근데 이때 미세 입자들이 정전기 날라 붙듯이 날라 붙습니다
그리고 뭉치고 얼어붙으면서 덩어리가 만들어지고
이게 태양에서 멀리 떨어진 차가운 영역에서
얼음 덩어리들이 씨앗처럼 점점 커져서 되는 거죠
그리고 나중에 목성이나 토성 같은 거대한 행성들이 자리를 잡으면
이때 작은 얼음 덩어리들을 중력으로 튕겨내기 시작합니다
그래서 해성 후보들은 두 곳에 나눠서 저장이 됐어요
그 두 곳이 바로
1. 카이퍼벨트
해왕성 바깥 원반
그 다음에 두 번째, 더 먼 곳에는 태양계를 둘러싼 구형의 저장고가 만들어져요
그래서 오르트구름이 만들어지죠
그래서 카이퍼벨트와 오르트구름
이 두 곳에 흩어져서 해성의 후보들이 저장이 됐고
이들의 기원을 우리가 알게 됐죠
그리고 이 얼음 덩어리가 궤도적으로 저장되고
그 궤도를 벗어나요
그렇게 해서 수십억 년 동안 계속해서
이 얼음 덩어리가 냉동 보관 상태로 잠들어 있다가
근처의 어떤 별의 중력 혹은 은하의 어떤 조성력
이런 자극을 받잖아요
이 얼음 덩어리 하나가 지구 쪽, 태양 쪽으로 낙하를 합니다
그러면서 우리가 아는 해성이 시작이 되는 거죠
그래서 오늘 특강 준비하면서 이제 마무리를 어떤 이야기로 할까
지금 정확히 약속된 시간입니다
오, 예, 예
어떤 이야기로 마무리할까 생각했는데
어떻게 이렇게 딱 맞춰요?
제가 사실 완벽하게 지킬 수 있어요
야, 너 그러면 그동안 왜 안 지킨 거야?
그동안, 그동안도 사실 하렘 할 수 있었어
어, 뭐야
어쩔 수 없었다며, 항상 어쩔 수 없, 쩔 수 없다, 쩔 수 없다
사실 다 할 수 있었어
뭐야
이실직고합니다
원성을 사고 있습니다
사실 계획이었어요
나 사실 질문도 계속 했었는데
나 때문에 안 됐다고, 내가 질문해가지고 안 됐다고
우리 윤화 님 스킬상 약속이 됐기 때문에
나는, 나는, 내 약속은
야, 친구 사이에 무슨
근데 왜 악수, 술을, 예
네, 알겠습니다, 어쨌든
그래서 마무리를 어떻게 할까 했는데
저는 이런 생각을 합니다
어쩌면 우리 인생이
혜성처럼 살아야 되지 않을까라는 생각을 했어요
혜성 차이나 혜성처럼
이게 무슨 의미냐
우리가 이제 인생을 삽니다
우리 여러분들이 다 인생을 살아요, 근데
저는 이런 마음가짐으로 사는 것 같아요
우리가 지나온 자리를 보고
다른 누군가가 경탄하면서 바라볼 수 있다면
그렇게 경이롭고 반짝거리는 궤적을 그릴 수 있다면
멋진 인생이 아닐까
그래서 우리가 지나온 자리가
얼마나 아름다운지
얼마나 정말 반짝거리는지
그런 것들을 보면서
정말 인생은 해성처럼 살아야 된다
우리가 아니라 우리가 지나온 자리를
누군가 보면 정말 멋지겠다
마지막으로 멋진 궤적을 늘 그리고 계신
멋진 먼지 꼬리
이온 꼬리를 만들고 계신 우리 유나님의
사건의 지평선을 청해드리면서
오늘 특강을 마무리하도록 하겠습니다
사건의 지평선도 들을 수 있어요?
아니 사건 좀 들어봐야죠
이번에 나오는 유나님의
신곡 여러분들도 많이 사랑해주시고
3월 9일에 발매가 될 예정이니까
많이 많이 들어주시면 감사하겠습니다
알겠습니다
그래서 유나님의 마지막 곡 사건의 지평선으로
마무리 짓고 저희는 물러나보도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다
KMR 주세요
This song support me
Foreign
You
We
배도 님이 해주세요.
있을 거야 아낌없이 반짝인 시간은
조금씩 옅어져봐도 나도 너와 내 맘에 살아 숨 쉴 테니
노래 좋은데?
아이 노래 맞췄어.
스웨이크 어스.
와 진짜.
아 너무 잘 들었습니다.
이거를 앉아서 사실은 이게 말이 안 되는 거예요.
앉아서 진짜 편안하게.
아 본인 꺼드럭대는 거예요?
이거 엄청.
앉아서 불렀다고?
아니 이 노래 엄청 어려운 거야.
이거 숨 쉬는 타이밍도 없거든.
제가 생각해보니까 뽑기를 안 했어요.
게스트 오시면 특별 선물을 드리거든요.
아무런 기대 없이.
기대 없이.
이야.
보자 보자 보자 보자.
현금 5만 원 걸렸습니다.
이야 세뱃돈.
식사하세요.
와.
뒤집고 싶은데.
뒤집어도 돼요.
그래놓고 이제 또 침착맨 굿즈 이런 거 나올 수 있어서.
렛츠 고.
가자.
침착맨 굿즈 나오면 좋지.
많이 살았구나 있으니까.
있으니까.
일단 5만 원은 아니야.
뭐지 뭐지 뭐지 뭐지?
그런 거 없어.
침착맨 그립토.
축하드립니다.
지금은 구하기 힘든 건데.
아니 집에 너무 많아 이거.
아니야 아니야 아니야.